e
ready to go ahead with HB
651 this is Bill modifying the base cost
and differentiated cost of an adequate
education prior that I have just two
notices for the committee committee
members if you're parking your vehicle
in a place that shouldn't be parked
other words if you're seeing one of the
yellow covers that goes on the parking
meters out out there and you think well
that's open to anybody's in in the uh
house you're wrong it's open to those
which that place has been assigned to
they're usually handicapped or have
medical conditions where they have to be
close by so do not do that I've been
told that you're going to be immediately
informed and regardless of what we're
doing here you're going to be pulled out
and you're going to have to go move that
car so just a word of advice be careful
the other one is if you're going to be
eating anything in that other room we
had a large spot last night which was a
stain on the carpet if you accidentally
spill something I have no problem with
that we just got to get to the uh people
are custodians and have it cleaned up so
it doesn't settle in and it's very
difficult to get out so those just a
couple quick notices um I think but we
also have a fiscal note on this a
revised fiscal note on 651 it's going to
be delivered here in a few moments uh
but I at to begin with I'd like to uh
welcome represent luno to our committee
and uh he will be presenting the
bill welcome thank you very much Mr
chair members of the uh committee for
the record uh Dave luno uh representing
the people of Hopkinson and Bo and all
across the United all across the state
of New Hampshire and um and uh and it's
a a a a delight for me to be here this
morning to introduce House Bill 651 so
651 is um is uh very similar to um to
Bill that we introduced last week House
Bill 550 and it's part of a package of
um of of public school funding bills
that we're going to be bringing on and
uh and looking forward to uh to getting
them introduce and getting them into a
work session so that we can really uh
really uh dig into this um
um unlike 550 I should say Let me let me
say it this way um 651 Builds on what we
talked about last week in House Bill 550
it includes a an increase to the base
cost of an adequate education based on
the um the ruling in the um uh in the
conal suit but it also
um increases the uh the differentiated
Aid costs that are um that that that are
part of our current um school funding
formula and that are that are included
in the in the r and case which is um
which is still this part of it is still
in the um in the lower in the in the
trial court so so um let's talk a little
bit about what U what um what the Rand
case is about so the Rand case is about
fairness it's about equity and um and
it's about fairness for
taxpayers because what it uh what it
what it includes is uh it prohibits um
um swept the state wide education
property tax discount or rebates uh it's
also includes fairness for students so
it recognizes the additional educational
cost uh based on student characteristics
and um you know I think most people
around around you know the committee
table here you know recognizes that
special education certainly comes with
it additional costs on a per student
basis but there are other factors too
which have a strong correlation to cost
so um so students or percentages of
students that come from lowincome
backgrounds and the way we measure that
in New Hampshire is through the number
of students or the percentage of
students in any school district that um
um that that uh take part in the free
and reduced price lunch program so we
use free and reduced price lunch as a
proxy for um uh for for low income but
there's other ways to do it too I mean
you could look at at Medicaid Direct
certific I think there's going to be a
bill on that later on today and that's
that's something that's also allowed at
the federal level to to be used as a uh
as a proxy for for low income another um
characteristic student characteristic
that um that
that that basically has costs associated
with it are um are students that that
don't have English is their first
language so English language Learners
and um and you know in a lot of
districts around the state there aren't
many elll students um in those districts
but uh but in districts like Manchester
and NASA I mean I I hear about how
Manchester has has students that speak I
think over 70 different uh different
language and that certainly imposes
challenges on the district as far as
providing an opportunity for an adequate
education for these students um but
there's um there's other factors that uh
that can be relevant to um um you know
to to to student specific costs that um
uh that could be that could be used they
just hope it they just aren't collected
by the New Hampshire Department of
Education today so they're not at our
disposal to um uh to do but as we
consider these school funding bills and
consider what sort of equity factors we
want to uh we want to include down the
road we may want to begin collecting
collecting data um that uh that that
helps us provide um you know Equitable
funding for for um for kids across the
state so
um so what what's included in the bill
everybody's got a copy of it and I think
the fiscal notes coming I'll be talking
about that a little bit um the top part
of it on line um line seven uh is the
same as what we talked about last week
in House Bill 550 it um it increases the
the state share uh of a cost of
inadequate education from $4,100 to
$735 1 cent um uh 651 adds increases to
the three differentiated um costs U so
the the the Equitable factors that that
flow into our um adequacy formula so for
free indu Price lunch soxy for for low
income uh students who are English
language Learners and um peoples who are
receiving special education services and
then the um the last thing it does and
we did this in 550 as well um had a
there's a modification to 193 e2b U uh
paragraph one to add the necessary
specific resource elements so that as
base cost get recalculated every every
so often that um that it it factors in
the uh the specific elements that the U
that that the con that the judge and
conval put in in that order uh but what
it uh what it does not do what what 651
does not do and um and probably uh
probably should take a look at it is um
is is what are these Equitable factors
what are these Equitable um
characteristics that uh that should be
costed out and put into our formula and
um obviously we haven't seen the order
in Rand yet um as it pertains to this
but as we go into our work sessions
hopefully this committee will be able
toh to take a look at some of these
things so
um so let's see uh we talked about um
651 being a package of the school
funding bills and um and reviewing them
real quickly we talked about uh what we
what we introduced last week House Bill
550 it's a flat funding formula so it's
uh just changes the base the base
adequacy Grant every school district in
the state gets that base ad adequacy
grant for every um every student um in
District uh House Bill 651 we now
introduce the equity component in there
so it recognizes differentiable
differentiated or Equitable costs that
not every student has has the same
degree of um of of of cost maybe said a
different way different students with
different characteristics provoke um um
impose uh different challenges on a
school district in terms of education so
651 one introduces equity and then um uh
bill that we'll talk about soon uh I
think it just received the bill number
and and is now in this committee uh
we'll uh we'll go One Step Beyond that
and begin to look at taxpayer equity and
basically Fair uh access to resources
and it's part of the foundation
opportunity plan and um and that one
really breaks us out finally out of this
one siiz fits-all uh method of um of
funding schools so all of these all
these methods are talked about in the
2020 school funding report and gets into
all of them in in considerable uh detail
so
um let's get into the fiscal did the
fiscal note come around we have them
okay so um so
the the the current um the current
formula for for State funding uh for
public schools so this is the state
share of funding Public Schools so uh
300 63 million come from the Statewide
education property tax an additional
$717 million come from other nons swept
Revenue sources so this this comes comes
from the um from the state coffers for
total of um of of $1 b80 million and
that's that's current um school funding
House Bill 550 what we did last week
increases that by approximately $454
million so the swep stays the same 363
million um the the direct funding
adequacy grants to school districts
increases from 717 million to um uh to
$171 million so that's the $454 million
increase House Bill
651 uh increases that I'm looking at my
numbers not necessarily the actually but
they're they're right on the same
increases it by another 570 I'm sorry
increases above current U by 576 million
so an increase uh it's U uh leaves swept
the same uh total direct ad adequacy
Grant of 1,293 million uh for a total
State share of
$1.65 billion which is um which is
getting close to 50% of what what what
we spend all all all in on public
schools in the state so largely driven
by local property uh taxpayers but also
uh a couple hundred million in federal
grants and then the um uh and then the
state Grant so so starting to approach
with House Bill 651 uh to a u to to
almost a 50% um you know 45 to 50% share
of um of school funding we're not
looking to increase um uh how much we
spend Statewide on public schools just
increased the state share uh of that and
provide a little bit Pro provide some
Sub sub substantial release relief for
property taxpayers um I think the uh the
fiscal note and again I haven't I
haven't gone through it it does um talk
about the cascading effect to Charter
Schools and um and vouchers so that is
um uh is in here and
um and anyway I uh look forward to uh to
taking any questions but I really look
forward to this heading into a uh a work
session with all of our school funding
bills so that we can really you know
shake them down and and uh and and and
see what works for the people in New
Hampshire thank you very much uh rep
luno and um we understand this is a
sequence a part of all the bills which
you you you know put together here and
it's they'll come back thank you no I
appre I appreciate that Mr and I
appreciate the fact that the the order
that these are being introduced because
they build they do build on each other
yes I understand representa papit do you
have a question thank you Mr chair I
have two but I'll start with one and ask
for your permission for the second one
thank you very much for U my opportunity
to ask questions and thank you to my
colleague for
testifying I'm only in my second term so
I still have a lot to learn here can you
share any scientific studies that show
that educating lowincome students is
more expensive and show by how much yes
we actually do have them they're they're
they're actually summarized in the
report and there's copies of the report
in the in the office but also there are
um there are specific subject matter
studies that are on the um the the
school funding commission's website
which is hosted by the Cary School UNH
and there's about um um a dozen or so uh
research papers based on new H using New
Hampshire's specific data but also
leaning on um on studies that the
American Institutes of research thank
you and Mr chair may ask my second thank
you question um you mentioned additional
funding forl I was wondering if you have
a thought on what should be the maximum
number of years we give to a school
district to bring a kid up to speed on
the English language so the ESL bumping
funding is no longer needed yeah I'm I'm
not an expert in that area I think it's
a great um a very good question though
um but um but I'm I'm not I'm not equi
thank you so much I appreciate it
further questions from from the
committee uh yes
representan thank you for bringing this
and thank you thank you Mr chairman um I
have a couple of questions if it's all
right real quick both in line with each
other the first one is why is the
greatest amount of differentiated Aid
given to free and reduced lunch and not
to special ad when special ad has such
an incredible cost so thank you very
much for the question um what um uh uh
the way the way we we did it 651 is we
just provided the same scaling factor
from from the base to the to the conv
Val base and we applied that to our
existing differentiated Aid factors so
in fact while the while the numbers are
different um it it's still the the um
the free in reduced price lunch uh would
still be greater than special education
as it is in our current Formula okay the
second question is this is numbered by
residency or enrollment I'm I'm thinking
this is numbered by enrollment there
what are you talking about the numbers
are figured by enrollment the in the
fiscal note yes yeah th those are by
admr that's how that's calculated no the
entire the the entire program the the
this state um Grant would be given to
the schools according to the number
enrolled to the N to the the the the
um not to the number of students
enrolled it's to the admr um there there
is a difference between enrollment and
and admr so all right average daily
membership in
residents all right thank you yeah
further questions represent
Burton thank you Mr chairman uh to
relate this back to previous testimony
uh about the preparedness of students
and the difference in where they come
from we can go back to the do you have a
question yeah I do okay does does the
testimony we heard about the number of
students is showing up at community
colleges uh needing developmental math
developmental English we call it uh many
coming from the lower income towns does
that give evidence that this part of the
process of education at the secondary
level if it's not adequate shows up when
they when they show up for Workforce
training community colleges and other
yeah no that's a that's a really good
observation U represent Burton and um
and again that's something that's um
that's talked about quite qu quite at
length uh in here with a very very
strong correlation between student
outcomes and um and and uh family income
where that where that student um lives
and actually um and actually overall
school funding um in those uh in those
districts so so so you know it's
important and our current funding
formula actually recognizes that um that
students from from lowincome uh
backgrounds and districts that have
large large numbers of students and
low-income backgrounds uh actually
require additional additional funding if
you want to improve their outcomes and
have the outcomes more in line with with
Statewide outcomes which are among the
best of the best in the country so uh so
even the new um the new um um uh the new
Equitable Grant the extraordinary needs
Grant recognizes um recognizes that um
uh that
Dynamic further questions from the
committee not seeing you thank you very
much thank you very much Mr chair uh
Shen good morning uh my name is Zach
Shen I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire school funding fairness
project uh we're here in support of
House Bill
651 um as representative luno mentioned
a little bit in his uh introducing of
the bill you know this kind of is a a
building on um house B 550 and some of
the testimony that was heard last week
on that the main difference being the
addition of the differentiated Aid
categories um and just to provide a
little more context about why this is an
important shift um that goes both in
line with some of the conv Val rulings
and Decades of of work to try to shift
some of the um cost from local property
taxpayers to the state again not
necessarily increasing total
expenditures overall but shifting who
pays uh right now um in New Hampshire uh
about $2.7 billion of the total amount
we spend on education is uh picked up by
local property taxpayers about 70% of
all of our education spending for our
Public Schools is paid for by local
property taxpayers the largest
percentage in the country by quite a bit
uh on the flip side less than 20% um
year toe right about 20% of funding for
public education actually comes from the
state of New Hampshire through our
adequacy formula and other Aid um
categories uh and that is the lowest
share in the country so on one hand
highest share comes from local property
taxes on the other hand lowest share
comes from the state uh and the Gap
there is largely um borne out in the
adequacy formula that we start to see um
being talked about in House Bill 651 uh
the state's providing uh just about
$5,200 $5,300 per student inadequacy
funding right saying this is an amount
of money you need to provide the cost of
adequate education for every K through2
student in the state while the actual
average expenditure is O over
$22,000 so there's a significant Gap
there in what the state's providing and
saying you can use that money to provide
an adequate education and what districts
all over the state are actually spending
um to to support their Public Schools uh
it has a huge impact on local property
tax rates which again is a big part of
this discussion by shifting some of the
share to the state we can provide more
relief for some districts who then could
reduce the property tax burn or at least
take the pressure off just one quick
example um in Kingston the equalized
school property tax rate that's swept
and and local is
$10.72 the expenditures um are
$24,600 uh per pupil uh in Hampton
almost the same exact expenditures
24,900 and yet the tax rate is about
half at
$615 and so we see kind of pretty
significant disparities around the state
largely based on property value and
hital 651 seeks to address some of these
inequities by increasing both the base
accuracy cost and some the
differentiated Aid um one element of the
current uh differentiated Aid costs that
I want to point out is that they're not
actually based on any real data math
math actual need the numbers passed in
the last budget were perfectly round
numbers
$4,100 2,300 for special education 800
for elll 2100 for free introduced lunch
there were that was a compromise number
between the governor's budget The
house's budget the Senate's budget to to
pass the budget some of the numbers you
know that we see in the lawsuits are
based on significant amounts of data 5
years of a court case these are values
that have been dug into picked apart I
really encourage anyone um to look into
the rulings or the conval lawsuit as
filed for some of the rationale around
why they got to the numbers they did um
and why the judge ended up at the 73
56 also just point out again that the
the state in the conval lawsuit right
provided absolutely no evidence over
five years that the
$4,100 was enough to provide an adequate
education there's no defense to that and
so really the question then is okay what
elements of the plaintiff's argument the
piece that they included that some of
them are in House Bill 651 really should
be included in the cost of an adequate
education two last pieces one um is uh
that again to reiterate this is about
who is paying not necessarily increasing
costs um and that there has been
significant um conversation recently um
about some legislative leaders other
state leaders to to strip some local
control and kind kind of force some of
these cost shifts onto the Local
District you know saying we're going to
kind of either cut or reduce spending at
the local level instead of the state
taking a look at what it should provide
to help balance that out help make it
less lopsided at 70% and
20% um and I think that really the the
question is how much should the state be
picking up in order to provide that
relief to local property taxes the last
thing I want to point out I'm happy to
answer questions after um is just uh
since this is building on house will 550
very similar Concepts I would really
encourage anyone if you want to look for
extra testimony or support there to look
back at the um the log for Hospital 550
188 people from 66 different communities
all over the state submitted written
testimony online for that bill um there
was almost 500 folks who signed in in
support um compared to the 11 who signed
in again so I just wanted to flag that
as the school funding bills sometimes if
you're not paid to be here right it's
hard to show up or testify in person or
even know how to track a bill and so
there's significant support um for that
bill last week and I hope that you kind
of bring that into the work sessions
around all these education funding bills
U and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much are there questions
from yes
representative thank you thank you thank
you for taking my question um
so I have to say that um and yes this is
a question for the last seven years I
have been on my school board and every
year at the annual meeting I've gotten
up and said
listen New Hampshire is the lowest in
the country for State funding you need
to speak to your legislator legislator
about how we fund education in New
Hampshire now I am a legislator and this
is my
fight we are the lowest you if we would
you please have a question we want the
questions first folks oh okay sorry if
this were to happen do you know where
that would put us it's obviously not
going to raise us up into the like 90th
you know but do you know where it would
put us I think so what you're asking is
if we this bill were to go in place as
written where would it Place us as
opposed to last in the state for state
share funding I don't know that the top
of my head somewhere in the middle okay
right so I can get an exact data point
but definitely not catapulting to you
know first or second in the country it
would be somewhere in the middle thank
you y further questions represent
papovich thank you Mr chair and thank
you again for being here and testifying
on multiple bills um I just wanted to
understand in your opinion is the intent
of this bill to increase total funding
or just to keep school funding the same
and shift cost from the local
communities to the
state I think the intent of this bill is
to I mean it's increasing the state
share of
funding I can't predict exactly what
every single school district will do
with that increased funding I think a
lot of them would see that and be able
to pass on those cost savings the
additional funding as property tax
relief to their um to their constituents
to their communities I so I think the
intent is twofold I think it's both to
increase the state share right but also
to recognize that it's reducing the
burden on property
taxpayers thank you did that answer
reasonably close thank you and if I may
have a follow up yes you may thank you
and the other question I had for you was
you testify that you know some of the
differentiated AIDS are round numbers
and I'm kind of curious given the
disparity in the needs of various towns
do you believe the state can actually
find a number that appropriately
reflects the differentiated Aid need for
every town you know with making it less
round help I
mean good
question um I don't think that making it
less round would necessarily be better
just because it would be a less round
number my point was
that the numbers here were not derived
from actual costs they were not derived
from linked to the commission of stud
School fundings numbers they were a part
of a negotiation process and I'm
encouraging um I think it would be
helpful to look
at areas where there's a lot of data
such as the court cases the commission
of study school funding to actually
answer the question that you've been
asking asked the the representative
introduce the bill what are these costs
how do we go about finding how much if
if much more at all different categories
of students require um and using more
datab backed reasons to to figure those
out thank you y further questions from
the committee yes representative
representative pH thank you um to follow
up on that last question do you think
that this um one siiz fits-all approach
so for example in every single um School
District that this that each student we
want to fund the it's appropriate to
fund the $
7,356 for each regular student in all
school districts and for the speal same
question with a special ed um no same
question with the free and reduced um
$4,000 per each uh free and reduced
student I think that's a better example
because if you had what if you only had
2% free reduced students in the district
does it make sense to fund that District
at all in terms of free and reduced I'm
also thinking about in terms of size
smaller districts the per pupil cost is
going to be larger than in larger
districts so I'm just questioning the
this this is not not a perfect bill I
guess is would be my answer to that and
all the points you're bringing up are
good points smaller districts in general
tend to have higher per people
expenditures holding other factors
constant some districts have lower
amounts of students living in poverty
some have higher amounts um and
increasing base adequacy as the way this
bill lays out in same as 550 would just
you know on its face be an increase to
every school district in the state would
that be the fairest most Equitable way
no it's a more equal way and it's taking
into account more again more of the data
and the actual what is the cost of an
adequate education not just what can we
afford and then backfill a definition
from there so I think this is a start I
it's a good place to build from but I
think there's a lot of factors some of
what you pointed out that would actually
make it more Equitable and answer the
question what does every student and
community and School District in the
state actually need to succeed and
provide that adequate
education yep further questions from the
committee yes representa
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
my taking my question and for your
ongoing yearslong work on this could you
just speak briefly about the impact of
our
current um small percentage of State
funding for public
schools on the difference in quality of
Education among
districts yeah so there's you know again
this comes back to when you you rely so
heavily on one tax base in this case the
local property tax base everything else
stems from that so communities that
don't have in general um whether it be
you know you're on 93 or more more
likely close to a lake ski mountain SE
coast and have significant property
value to boost up the overall amount of
property value that you're able to tax
from if you don't have that which is a
lot of communities in the State uh 76%
of students live in communities with
below average equalized value per pup so
don't benefit from this system and what
you see with that is by having a smaller
tax base and having to have higher tax
rates puts more strain on the
communities right makes passing budget
increases a lot harder makes um funding
for the schools a much bigger stretch
for the residents in the town you see a
pretty clear connection to number of AP
classes to teacher turnover rates to
average teacher salaries to starting
teacher salaries to number of sports
teams um you see a real clear connection
to the things and the opportunities that
different school districts are able to
provide largely based on their funding
which again is largely based on the
heavy Alliance on local property taxes
so there is a Clear Connection there's
been a lot of research and and um data
that has laid that out and we see that
in the opportunities that are available
for students the age and quality of the
buildings you know do your build are
your buildings falling down do they have
um you know infestations of one type or
another or are they are you able to
renew them every few decades and keep
them up to dat which all have
significant impacts on student learning
outcomes thank you further questions
from the
committee yes representative Burton
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question in 1986 when we were
first working on this do you have a
question yes please ask the question go
ahead is there a direct correlation
between student achievement and
expenditure per student there was a
study published in 1985 that showed that
in the union leader we never saw it
again yes there is a connection um you
know just like any other expenditures
right there's going to be a point at
which it has less of an impact and for
some students there's going to be a
larger impact on expenditures and
outcomes but there is no question that
there is an impact and a relation
between increased funding and outcomes
for students especially for students
that come from lower income families or
have um other needs that they need
resources for to to meet those needs and
and have access to the education like
their peers um and again there's a you
know reducing effect as you go higher up
or if you already have a student that is
relatively High achieving does not need
bunch of additional Services more money
for that individual student might not
make as big of an impact but yes we've
seen that in New Hampshire and all over
the country um basically that yes money
does matter thank you thank you Mr
chairman further questions yes represent
pop thank you Mr chair just a brief
follow up to the previous questions you
said there is a link between spending
per student and educational outcomes I
want to understand whether it's a
correlation or a causation and if it's a
causation whether you have again studies
to show that thank
you my understanding is that it is a
causation um and I can find I'm happy to
send the committee there's again it's
like the framing is does money matter
raised the question and there is a
report that's put out that says Money
Matters and by I believe the education
Law Center don't quote me on that I can
send it but yes there are studies and
again higher impact for some students
and some communities coming from more
need who had a question on that side
represent fellis and then represent cian
um um would like to hear your um
perspective on um the possibility or the
appropriateness of including in our
school funding
a minimum teacher salary and I the
reason I ask that is because we know
that there are some school districts
which hire new teachers with a salary
that's below 40,000 a year and that
those districts seem to be training
districts because te they'll get the new
teachers and after three years they go
to a different district and certainly
exper an experienced teacher is more
likely to be able to to help kids learn
that's a great question I think you're
referring also to the Newport the
testimony from the Newport
superintendent last week that made that
comment about the kind of training
ground um I I think that would be a
conversation between the the state the
legislature and how much control you
want to exert over local school
districts um that could be if you want
increased funding instead of Base
minimum salary I think that would be an
interesting approach um where that would
intersect with collective bargaining and
local school districts I think it's
pretty complicated but I definitely
think that teacher salaries are a huge
impact um and I think that'd be an
interesting thing to
explore thank you rep represent
cran um I I'm not sure if included in
this the what the state funds Public
Schools as far as I don't know if it
comes under maintenance does anyone in
the state inspect school
buildings uh and is that included in the
cost that's provided
um especially for buildings that
are Health that have health issues that
affect the people that work within them
we we do have doe here and works with
the State Board perhaps rather than
somebody that's not working for doe to
answer that question for you regarding
do they go out and inspect these
buildings Etc does that want to hold off
on that question till we have technical
you took the words out of my mouth they
would be the best ones to answer that
further further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much thank you uh the next person I'd
like to invite up is Brian Eaton Brian
department and he's here for technical
support and perhaps represent CED and
you can move your first your question
had good morning my name is Brian and
I'm with the Department of Education
Bureau of school Finance what you have
being passed now is a memo um I wasn't
aware the fiscal note would make it to
today so I want to prepare a memo to
summarize the analysis that the
department had done um for fiscal impact
for this bill um so I can quickly review
this it's no more information than what
represent uh luno had introduced before
just mostly summarizes it uh the top
table will show you the changes in each
of the rates and then the bottom table
will show you the changes in each one of
the aid and representative luno had
described that um about that uh impact
to adequate education Aid and then he
had hinted and um alluded to that
there's also um impacts a charter in EFA
which he didn't uh wasn't too sure about
um specifically as as familiar with the
adequate education Aid so so there will
be an impact to Charter a a and EFA a
because both of those uh formulas do
reference that initial RSA that's being
uh modified um
1984a so that is mostly what the bill is
and this analysis was done without um
any any interaction with any other bills
I know that was talked about earlier
that it was designed to be introduced
and um executed in in um in conjunction
with another bill we didn't interpret
that and we didn't put that into this
analysis so this is purely just the
impact of this bill and what it would
have on uh State funding so I can
provide any um explanation or any
insight to the fiscal note for this bill
or any other questions related to The
Bill thank you Brian I I know you're
from the finance department uh we have
Miss White here though also it would I'm
trying to F figure out here who is the
best answer we can have other questions
for Brian regarding the fiscal notes
here but in terms that question right
there would be wiser for would you hand
that off to your other cohort here I I I
don't believe I maybe I not sure if you
have any insight to
that it's related to Building
Inspections um neither of us are in that
there's a specific Bureau for for
inspections the department does conduct
inspections but I believe that's outside
of what's locally um the jurisdiction
and requirements for inspection as well
so I can't speak to spefic specifically
if if the funding for Education covers
that as well I imagine it would either
from State funding or local um education
tax I'm sure it comes out of that budget
if it needs to ref cran is that your
question you're looking for or response
um yeah I wanted I just wanted to know
if within that cost there is are people
from the state
inspecting buildings across the state
that may be in question of being healthy
um
safe buildings oh so if the funding out
of the education trust fund funds the
department to conduct those invest those
inspections I don't know off top of my
head I'm sorry we can have somebody
follow up from our department that's
specific that well the white division
director for learner support um I'm not
100% on that but I'm pretty sure that's
not coming out of the education trust
fund that that's coming out of General
funds to have um that team which is in
the division of analytics that's Caitlyn
Davis's the div division director for
that
so my understanding is that Bureau is
funded through General funds not
education trust funds but I'm not 100%
okay so that's the team that goes in and
does what was the name of the person uh
Caitlyn Davis and I can reach out to her
to make sure she responds to your
question are there there are there
questions for for the finance department
on this
bill represent fellows um yes I'm just
wondering if you can um explain a little
bit the um the charter Aid in the EFA
Aid you know why why those go up and
which numbers are you using to push
those up sure uh so like I mentioned
those the RSA that issues payment for
EFA Aid and Charter Aid those reference
the rates specified in 19848 which is
what this uh bill is modifying so for
our estimates we had utilized um to
estimate the charter ADM and EFA ADM to
come up with that estimate of total Aid
uh and so our estimates I believe for
Charter we had used
the uh we had used Trends between last
fiscal year and this fiscal year for so
at the time we only have um a couple
collections of enrollment for Charter
Aid and EFA up to this point we have a
full year because we pay it out
differently than adequacy so we pay out
EFA during the year that the students
are enrolled uh that's different than
District adequacy which is lagged by one
year so we only have a couple snapshots
of collection so we don't have a full
year of data to actually estimate so we
use Trends uh between last year
enrollment and this year so far to give
our best estimate of what it could
be further questions of the
department not SE thank you very much
for coming today are there any other
pink cards for this bill
not seeing any I will close the
hearing and we have few minutes here
before we start the next at 11:00 the
next bill is going to be relative to
State participation in the Medicaid
direct to certification program for free
meals
e
head here with the next bill here uh so
I'll give everybody a minute or two to
seats okay the the bill here
which we're addressing is uh Medicaid
direct monies which would be I'm
assuming a qualifier for free you know
getting more people eligible for support
in the education side of things and we
we've we've dealt with this before and
it's returning here to allow us to get
engaged in that program
so I'd like to go ahead we have six
cards here I'm assuming one is the
person that's the owner of the bill
sponsor and
so pardon
Mees yeah I'm trying to find that yeah
there it is right there
okay good morning
representative and welcome to uh
education funding and this is a subject
which we're sort of familiar with but
not familiar with total because there's
a lot of new people here on it so
welcome the Bill thank you so much Mr
chairman good morning everyone
thank you for having me here today I am
Laura tersi I represent nashua's Ward 8
which is Hillsboro 11 as the chairman
stated this is a topic that um many of
you know quite well and for some of you
it's new so I hope we can um sort of set
a baseline this
morning I present first I'll start I did
pass out two pieces of um written
testimony from uh people who could not
attend so I hope that you can add that
to your
um folder uh on this bill um I present
for your consideration House Bill
583 which would require the Department
of Education to utilize Medicaid direct
certification for the free and reduced
meals
program this school year there are a
total of 43 States participating in the
program
Nationwide I first want to share some
general information and data points on
Hunger here in the state of New
Hampshire for many families it has
become increasingly difficult to meet
basic needs with the rising costs of
housing Child Care Transportation and
overall expenses a recent survey from
September of 2024 found that 39% of New
Hampshire children lived in households
that reported having insufficient food
Statewide we've seen increased demands
on our soup kitchens food banks and
community services and with all of these
factors we know more than ever that
School meals both breakfast and lunch
have become even more essential to our
children's
well-being the school meal program is
critical to so many students when it
comes to health learning and overhaul
Behavior a child who is fed can focus on
learning without the distraction and
discomfort that hunger brings they have
better attendance fewer trips to the
school nurse allowing them to stay in
their classroom to learn and they have
better behavioral and academic outcomes
and higher graduation
rates when you look at both poverty
and childhood hunger as two adverse
childhood experiences or Aces we know
that feeding kids helps them learn
succeed and leads them to grow into more
successful contributing adults and
members of our community the school meal
program is an investment in public
health our future Workforce and the
future of our state I'd like to be clear
that this bill is not looking to raise
the income eligibility for the program
but simply is an attempt to help
identify students living in poverty who
who aren't being fed at school to
qualify for free meals a family needs to
be at or below 130% of federal poverty
and to qualify for reduced price meals
that limit goes up to 185% of federal
poverty and this bill does not change
that right now parents fill out the form
annually to participate or a family can
be automatically enrolled if they
participate in other assistance program
such as snap tanif Head Start or a few
other unique circumstances If the child
as homeless or foster child families
receiving snap and tanif benefits have
to submit their income information and
be verified and those families can be
directly certified into the lunch
program Medicaid is a public health
insurance for people with low incomes
and requires the submission of income
information and verification annually to
ensure eligib eligibility however
because of HIPPA and without USDA
authorization to participate in the
demonstration Project New Hampshire
Medicaid is barred from sharing the
information to be used for the N
National School meals program and the
language of HB 583 is very brief and
authorizes the Department of Education
to participate in the program I want to
dig into the numbers a little bit on why
this is needed and how we know that
there are low-income kids not in the
program when you look at the data the
number of children enrolled in Medicaid
in New Hampshire who meet the income
eligibility is greater than the number
of kids who are enrolled in the free and
reduced Mals program for this school
year there are nearly
4,900 public school students enrolled in
the meal program and using Medicaid data
the Department of Health and Human
Services have identified
meeting at school at a free or reduced
rate but they are
not think about how easy it would be for
these families if when they pulled
together their income information to
apply for Medicaid at the same time they
could apply for the school meal program
easier for families easier for schools
and more kids being
fed I'd like to point out that this bill
all by itself does not have a high cost
the fiscal note outlines what happens
when we accurately identify children in
poverty as this committee well knows the
state school funding formula recognizes
that children living in poverty
generally have higher educational needs
than other children that's why districts
receive increased aid for each child
living in poverty and the problem is in
how we identify those students who
qualify for that increased
Aid currently we look to the students
who are enrolled in the free and reduced
males program which on the surface seems
to make makes sense however as I just
shared uh we know for a fact that there
are more than 10,000 kids in this state
who are living in poverty and they are
not enrolled in the meals program that
means those kids aren't benefiting from
the meals program and their school
districts are not receiving adequate
compensation to support their needs I
believe that the state is already
obligated to provide additional funding
for children in those districts who are
living in poverty and should be getting
increased aid but not supporting the
bill due to the unintended consequences
is acknowledging and accepting the
weaknesses that exist in our current
Formula there are so many difference
sorry excuse me there are so many
benefits to Medicaid direct
certification for kids and families it
reduces childhood hunger improves access
to healthy meals increases academic
outcomes reduces costs for families and
streamlines the process for parents for
schools it feeds kids helps them to be
better Learners improves the class
classroom environment for all students
provides more federal funds to districts
cutting down on unpaid meal debt it
increases efficiency for School
Employees who have to process and verify
each family and it reduces enrollment
and verification errors I know that
there are a number of experts behind me
that would like to dig in more into how
this legislation will be impactful so I
will wrap it up but HB 583 is about
making sure that every child who
qualifies for free and reduced price
meals can easily enroll in the program
Medicaid direct certification is about
good Public Health by making sure kids
are fed as well as an example of true
government efficiency we have shown the
process works with SNAP and tanif and
other programs and it only makes sense
to use Medicaid enrollment thank you for
your thank you very much representative
committee Senor thank you very much
represent
Mahan I have one question really this is
actually just a way of automating um uh
a way of getting the kids on if they're
already certified for Medicaid is that
correct it's to make it actually Direct
that's correct thank you further
questions from the committee thank you
very
now
I'm not sure I understand the question
representative uh well the
the the statement um was that there's
currently uh direct certification if
families are enrolled in snap my
understanding is that snap is
underutilized um so that there were
probably I would assume many students
who are not automatically enrolled in
that program
that's correct I mean it's it's clear
that there are children
who's qualify to receive those benefits
of um available to snap and um I believe
that if if Medicaid direct certification
was implemented it would also help us to
identify those children whose families
would also benefit from snap thank you
very much further questions not see
thank you very much representa thank you
very much you're welcome uh representa
woodcock
all right shair members of the committee
thank you Steve Woodcock from Conway New
Hampshire um have take them off put them
on take them off put them on um i' like
to present a different perspective on
this
bill um today the issue on 583 is direct
certification is very clear it's pretty
simple actually I I mean as I look
around the membership of this committee
I see folks who are apparently well
educated probably degreed and they
understand the complexity of numbers
budgets analytics
Matrix percentages Etc most of you
probably received a check I was a guess
uh pre-co from the stimulus for $500 or
$600 and you accepted it and you spent
it because you're entitled to
it and
I bet many here receiving state or
federal VA pensions um or company IRAs
or 401s because you earn
those and I guess that as a worker
regardless of your income you paid your
taxes federal taxes and now you're
receiving perhaps a monthly Social
Security uh because you're entitled to
it likewise you may have Medicaid A B C
D or all the numbers letters who
knows but you're entitled to it but just
imagine if you were less educated
perhaps and couldn't understand the
system the relief or how to provide food
for your children you couldn't
understand the
paperwork but you're entitled to it just
think about it if you couldn't get your
Medicaid or your Social
Security now here's an option to provide
food to the hungriest children of
families of poverty and you ladies and
gentlemen can make that
happen this isn't a
handout this isn't an unfunded mandate
it isn't an extension of Eligibility of
any other law this is helping the
poorest Gran sters to a source of which
they are
entitled last session this bill failed
not because it was justified but rather
because folks down the hall said and
believe that this would cost too much
money what they really meant was the
decision had didn't have much to do with
food or feeding kids but the system the
money to which they were entitled as you
know it comes from state and federal
funds because they're entitled to it but
that
changes because it changes the free and
reduced allocations to Public Schools
the public schools that are actually
entitled to that money they should have
had that money the year before year
before year before I needed school
systems it wasn't about food without
paying our fair
share so I ask you today to to do the
minimum the minimum provide what's
entitled to last year which was 7868
youngsters I think was the number as the
representative said this morning that
number is increased almost by 30% of
students that are eligible and are
entitled to
it the state needs to fulfill their
obligation to provide families in the
school and funding to the schools that
they are entitled to using the entitled
funds for something other as a matter no
matter how valid the other sources are
no matter where we spend out the money
and state money in my mind that's
misappropriation of funds that we know
should be going to schools and the
children to which they're entitled to it
so I'm asking you here today to please
step up and provide money for this bill
and service the children and the schools
to the money that they are entitled to
thank you m thank you very much
representative and good morning back to
education uh are there any questions
from the committee represent kokom thank
you Mr chairman U put the glasses back
on
okay I'm not sure I understood you
correctly so I would like some
clarification okay on that last point
that you were making as far as the
school being entitled to this money sure
um what comes to mind is I'm one of 11
children that grew up in a household
with one income need a question I will
get to put we had plenty of food my
parents sent me to school with my lunch
and you're and therefore the school
didn't need to provide me lunch are you
saying that the school should still be
entitled to that money that I my parents
would have qualified for but chose not
to well thank thank you for for the
question representa what I'm saying um
and I'm sure R the lad will correct me
if I'm wrong because he knows the math
better than I do um what I'm saying is
that the schools receive additional
Aid dependent upon the number of
youngsters enrolled in the free and
reduce lunch program so if we add 10,000
or 7,000 youngsters who are already
already eligible and whose parents for
the most part don't know how to follow
the forms if we add them back to where
they should be because they are entitled
to it those school districts receive
more funding so if you have 10 more
youngsters in your school wherever you
happen to represent it comes out School
District that would be 10 more financial
aid free and reduced lunch allocation
stiens and rubs and correct the word but
additional lifeeast town so about 10,000
people 10,000 youngsters today cross the
state would provide
10,000 whatever the number is I think
it's 300 some dollars per youngster um
to that school system because they're
eligible for free and reduced lunch
that's all it is I'm not saying that
they should require to feed them I'm
saying they should require for the
school standpoint the school in the town
where you have to come from or city gets
extra funding for every youngster on
free reduce lunch just like they are
English Learners something similar and
I'm sure represent is the correct number
but that's that's the essence I'm not
going there represent no well he's doing
a hell of job though go ahead are there
further questions from the
committee did did I I'm ex m m that even
more confused than you
started no you didn't I just my point is
we would have qualified but we chose not
to because my parents provided us the
food so therefore the school was not
entitled to what we chose not to qualify
for or apply for okay my if I may well
I'd rather not get it going back no
there's no back and for it's just a
clarification the point was these these
folks in this bill today are not those
whose parents didn't apply for for the
most part these are parents who didn't
even have figure out how to use a system
and the direct certification is the
funnel is the channel for that system to
help those who can't figure it out thank
you very
much the next person is up are there any
more questions for represent whitcock
label
welcome good morning honorable chair and
members of the committee my name is tra
Bell and I'm a resident of Portsmouth
New Hampshire I'm a parent a former
School nutrition worker and someone who
has experienced hunger both personally
and professionally
I strongly support Medicaid direct
certification for free and reduced price
School meals while working in schools I
saw firsthand how many children go
hungry and how many families struggle to
navigate the school meal application
process the stigma of applying for free
and reduced meals in the complicated
paperwork often prevent families like
myself from seeking help I too qualified
but didn't apply because I was too
embarrassed Medicaid direct
certification would remove the stigma by
allowing families to automatically
qualify for School meals based on their
Medicaid enrollment making the process
simpler in ensuring more children get
the nutrition they
need hunger impacts children in many
ways not only physically but emotionally
and behaviorally I've witnessed children
go from being disengaged and upset to
smiling and ready to
learn this shows how critical it is to
address hunger in schools direct
certification can help reduce the number
of children coming to school hungry
particularly those families struggling
with the High Cost of Living it's
crucial to simplify the process for
providing School meals to Children
parents facing hardships prior
prioritize medical
insurance and applying for other
programs like Snap and Medicaid it's
already challenging and adding another
application for School meals just adds
to the burden and often discourages
families from
applying Medicaid direct certification
would reduce this barrier and ensure
more children would get the proper
nutrition they need in my community my
local food pantry has seen a 30%
increase in participation over the past
year an 80% increase since
2021 food and housing costs are on the
rise more families are struggling to
meet their basic needs and Medicaid
direct certification would help ensure
that children from families with incomes
at or below 185% of the federal poverty
level receive School meals for example a
family of two like myself in 2024 had to
earn less than $
37,8 14 for a child to qualify for a
reduced price
meal the long-term benefits of Medicaid
direct certification are clear Better
Health improved academic achievement and
a healthier more Equitable future for
all students simplifying the school meal
process is a vital step towards
addressing food insecurity I urge you to
support HB 583 to help New Hampshire
families access the school
meals thank you very much are there any
committee repres yes thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mel for testifying I just
wanted to um understand you testified
you saw many children go hungry can you
please provide us with any information
you have on any children being denied
food at school due to their inability to
pay or for any other
reason in the school district that I
worked at we didn't refuse children but
often children would feel like that they
couldn't because they knew that they
didn't have money on their account or
parents told them or they knew what they
shouldn't have known is that they didn't
have money on their account
um so children did often refuse even if
I told them not to worry about not to
worry about it um they would feel like
that they needed to listen to their
parents thank you thank you further
questions represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here and for sharing your
challenging personal experience so folks
can sort of put a face on the reality of
hunger um I'm noting in your testimony
and and you stated it that in 2024 a
family of two would need to earn less
than $
37,8 for a child to qualify for a
reduced meal and I just did the math if
you are working full-time that's
$18.17 an hour do you do you have a
question I'm right at it thank you thank
you um could you share or comment
on your experience or experience of
folks you know who are in fact working
full-time for wages of 18 or less per
hour who therefore would qualify for
this even though they're working
full-time I live in a large apartment
complex with many single parents and I
know firsthand several um I was one of
those people I worked at a school and
was feeding the kids and I earned less
than that thank you you're welcome thank
you very much are there further
questions thank you for coming today
thank you you're welcome uh next one is
osbor uh is it Adam
Adam welcome Adam no you you do a good
job
oops just my old
eyes there you I think this is still on
yeah um first of all I'd like to thank
you for for allowing me to testify today
on Medicaid direct certification my name
is Adam Osburn and I'm a I'm a principal
um locally in the town of Bo Bo Memorial
School
um and ironically I'm trying to
represent like the voice of school
leaders in in this process because I
think it's an important voice and
important perspective um in in BO
although we only have a 3% free and
reduced lunch rate I think there are
more kids that would qualify should a
bill like this be in in place um I think
it's a good bill I think it's a good
example of government efficiency and and
logically linking things that that do go
together and should go together
um so the bill will greatly improve
government efficiency and accuracy the
bill will directly link our Med Medicaid
eligible students with free and free and
reduced lunch Services we know that
Statewide free and reduced lunch numbers
um they're they're often a barometer of
how many kids are in poverty and how
many where where services and resources
should be directed to this bill would
then kind of coordinate that number with
the number of students on Medicaid to
make it a more accurate number and I
think that's got to be helpful um I
think that the free and reduced lunch
process can be daunting for some
families we' we've heard a lot about
that I actually had printed our own free
and reduced lunch application off our
website before I came in and just having
thumb through it it it is daunting it's
quite a few pages long there is a lot of
text there's a lot of reading um and if
you're not a person
who's that comes naturally to that could
be a real barrier this would remove that
barrier I think that's important um I
think there's also the matter of Pride
um which which um representative ccum
had talked about and I think that's real
I think that I think that's something we
need to recognize and I don't know if
that's something you build into the
legislation or not um maybe it is
because that's a I think we should
respect that um this bill though will
fundamentally ensure that students get
what they need Educators Who start down
their college pathway learning about
teaching and pedagogy and whatnot
quickly learn about maso's hierarchy of
needs and until you can meet those basic
needs that food that security
you're not going to be able to as
effectively get those students to learn
the rest of their lessons it's really
hard to focus on math when your stomach
growling at 9:30 in the morning um I
think there's some practical benefits as
well to the state and also to
municipalities it pass the the bill will
improve our accounting of students who
are actually living in poverty that's a
good thing for future resource
allocation across probably all of
Statewide Services um I think
additionally for a lot of towns and it
was alluded to earlier meal lunch debt
that's a real that's a real
consideration for a lot of towns because
very rarely do schools just push kids
away and say no you cannot eat like for
instance at our school we do not do that
but you end up running a debt at the end
of the year and that's just it's that's
got to come from somewhere this if you
put more kids on to free and reduce
lunch will help minimize that probably
won't make it go away but it will go a
long way toward dressing School Meal
lunch debt and then finally um I'm
definitely not an expert on full school
funding at all but it seems to me that
you folks are and you you've recognized
that it does cost more per pupil who for
students who are in poverty to educate
them and and you've set aside additional
funds for that and certainly if the
number is 10,500 additional students
that will qualify that's a pretty hefty
sum and I I appreciate that but I also
think it's the right thing to do because
it's about getting the resources to the
schools the towns and the municipalities
that really need that when you have a
higher concentration of free introduced
lunch students you have a higher need
that that goes along with those students
so I would encourage you to please
support this bill it seems like good
governance it seems like a very um
logical way to bridge services and I
appreciate you considering it thank you
I support this bill and hope you do too
thank you very much Adam are there
questions from the committee yes
represent
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming and taking my
question does the amount of money that
your school gets from this program is it
related to the number who of of students
who are signed up for the program or is
it related to the amount of meals they
actually come and eat I think it would
have to do with who is signed up I I
think once you're Medicaid ell I should
check that make sure I understand your
question are you talking about the
school funding formula portion the I I'm
not sure the exact number maybe $2,300
per pupil or are you talking about the
number of individual meal reimbursements
because that would be they're two
different answers like if it's the
individual meal
reimbursement if I'm a free introduced
lunch student I come through that's a
reimbursable meal if I do a 100
reimbursable meals in the course of the
year it would be reimbursed at that rate
but if it's the school as I understand
it and I don't profess to be an expert
but there's the secondary piece which is
really the trickle down cost that I
think you folks are probably going to be
considering which is the per pupil
additional funding for kids who qualify
for free and reduced lunch I I think
again not the expert at all and that
would be a different answer thank you
maybe somebody else will answer my
question yeah we we we've had that
response and the answer uh represent
Damon if you can do it in a you know a
cliff note manner I'd appreciate it so
the two
parts the differentiated Aid related to
a student being enrolled in fnr comes to
the school district for that student
regardless of whether they eat meals or
not correct the Federal funding for the
meals only comes if the child takes the
meals right so most children don't eat
every single meal that is available to
them every single day of the school
year they're absent or whatever um so
it's two different pieces um thank you
very much are there further questions
from the committee yet represent the
Fells then represent from papovich thank
you Mr chair and uh thank you for ask
answering my question I'm like that that
oh I apologize did I jump was it me I
did no no no if I jumped I apologies I
want to yield to representative fellows
my my apologies I you were on Deck
representative
fellows thank you um one of the things
that you you said was that the the
application is complicated so i' I've
seen the application I know what it
looks like and I understand they have to
provide you know pay STS and that sort
of thing I'm
wondering if putting the application
online is going to solve that problem
and if maybe there are other approaches
within the school that could address how
to get more people to sign up sure um
sure I believe that it's actually a
federal requirement of schools that we
send this home annually so each August
we'll print this probably 12 or 15 page
package which is not all application
there's there's a lot in it uh we send
that home with every single student
because that's what's kind of required
of us early in the school year and I I
think that's across the board in the
state um we also do have it online as
well we have it in two places so it's
we're we're hoping to break down those
barriers now now we have another bill
coming up that has that involved in it
and this bill is about medic Direct in
the process that comes from that other
agency the monies or permission for and
there are a lot of issues associated
which are policy type issues that we may
have to consider but let's do that at an
another time uh when we have our work
session this we need to keep this to
Medicaid direct
today rep papovich thank you Mr chair
and again I would like to apologize for
inadvertently misunderstanding the
chairman and jumping the gun I apologize
for the confusion and thank you for
taking my question um I'm curious what
does does your school district do at the
end of the year with the unpaid School
launch that do you write it off
obviously by writing it off I mean do
you pay it from other do you move money
to pay for it or do you aggressively
pursue the parents to collect we're
actually kind of a bad example because
in BO we are not running a school de
yeah we we're our our lunch meal that is
we are not in that boat I know most
municipalities are but we are
not yeah that's a community it's not
done have many people in that program so
it's I'm good I'm going to give you the
information represent Mahan thank you
for taking my question I'm curious about
something um representative Damon asked
does does this mean that when when we've
increased by by this automated process
that when we've increased the amount of
people on free and reduced launches does
that also mean that the differentiated
you're going to go stands to increase as
well I believe so yes I think that if if
there were another say five students in
b just making it up if five students
were then Medicaid eligible and that was
linked to free and reduce lunch that I
believe would trigger that
additional is it $2,300 per pupil that
would go to the district or thereabouts
yeah yes the answer is yes represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I remembered my
question that I forgot when I was
explaining before thank you for taking
my question um so two parts it's my
understanding that most school districts
and I think this might be in the federal
stat statutes on the meals must have a
designated
person who would if a family member was
receptive to this facilitate their
filling up the
application is that correct I don't know
if it's a federal requirement we would
help them for for certain yeah challenge
getting them in the door yeah and then
um separately may I in a question yes
um do you see cost savings perhaps more
or in districts that have a larger
number of f&r students qualifying cost
savings because the administrative
process would be considerably less with
direct
certification I would imagine that as a
yes because it's going to limit the
number of hands touching the the forms
it's going to nmit the amount of time
with the application process thank you I
there further questions from the
committee thank you very much for coming
today thank you what what level School
do you have I have Middle School five to
eight ra five what a challenge thank you
very
much
yeah I think kindergarten can
be okay uh the next one
Maryfield uh
Stacy am I
correct thank you
that' be fine they just grab a chair and
up now you guys still have you know to
you sorry I thought it was
on um thank you all for being here today
and hearing our Testament and Board of
House Bill
583 um I'm Stacy Maryfield I'm the
director of culinary and nutrition for
New Hampshire food bank and this is Mary
Hammer she's our nutrition programs
manager um as the only food bank in the
state the New Hampshire Food Bank a
program of Catholic Charities New
Hampshire has worked for more than 40
years to ensure that all Granite Staters
have access to the food and resources
that they need to
thrive um the New Hampshire Food Bank
also partners with feeding America which
is the largest charity working to end
Hunger nationally in the United States
this partnership allows us to leverage
their reach and
resources um through our work at the New
Hampshire food bank we can attest to the
issue of food insecurity in our state in
20124 we distributed more than 17
million pounds of food um which was in
an increase of approximately 1 million
from the previous year and it still was
not enough um current ly the New
Hampshire Food Bank distributes food to
more than 400 partner agencies such as
food pantries homeless shelters and
children's programs and more throughout
the entire State on average these
partner agencies receive approximately
60% of the food they distribute from the
New Hampshire food bank and children
comprise approximately 35% of the
population
served according to feeding americ most
recent move the mic close can you get it
closer in yeah okay according to feeding
America's most recent map the meal Gap
report released in May of 2024 one in 10
individuals in New Hampshire face food
insecurity including one in seven
children several of the New Hampshire
food banks nutrition programs serve
children specifically to highlight two
of these the recipe for Success program
produced and distributed over 30 5,000
meals in 2024 to Boys and Girls Clubs
located in five different cities and
towns in New Hampshire and our
sponsorship last year of the
USDA summer food service feeding I'm
sorry the summer food service program
now known as Sun
meals allowed us to facilitate the
production and distribution of over
106,000 meals for children during the
summer
months these examples help demonstrate
the significance of child childhood food
insecurity and the need for additional
Solutions Medicaid direct certification
will help address this issue by
increasing food access for children
eliminating the need to complete an
application for free and reduced price
meals for qualifying children will help
prevent this from being a barrier to
program enrollment and make it easier
for children to have access to the food
they need to grow and learn at school we
hope that you will support HB 583 to
help reduce childhood food insecurity in
New Hampshire thank you for your time
and your
consideration thank you very much both
committee thank you for what you do to
the community appreciate it thank you I
I don't see any other further questions
so thanks again okay you're wel thank
good morning thank you for hearing my
testimony uh my name is Megan brabeck I
live in New Market and I am here today
representing thousands of save the
children Action Network supporters
across the state scan is the advocacy
arm of save the children and we're
building bipartisan support to make sure
that every child has a strong start life
and that includes working to end child
hunger right here in New Hampshire and
across the country
in June of this past year 2024 we
commissioned a national poll that found
that voters of all backgrounds are
struggling with the cost of living and
want the government to do more to
address these needs um I want to share a
few takeaways from that poll uh food and
grocery prices were the largest the
second largest I apologize problem
identified by the people pulled after
the cost of housing and that sentiment
was shared across party affiliations and
across all other demographic markers 87%
of the poll participants said that the
government should be doing more to help
families struggling with food and
groceries consistently across those
demographic and party lines um we also
conducted a state specific survey last
month in December here in New Hampshire
and that survey found that 71% of New
Hampshire voters view the cost of food
and groceries as a very serious or
extremely serious issue voters want to
see this legislature take steps to make
it easier for kids and families to
access food passing this as an
opportunity for you to do just that uh
we have a number of Advocates across the
state as I mentioned um who wanted to be
there today um but we're not able to
come and so I wanted to share the
thoughts of just one of those Advocates
um Ben Buckley who is a new father from
New Market as well shared the following
statement children in New Hampshire
deserve to attend schools that give them
an excellent learning experience the
opportunity to socialize with peers
provide access to healthy food and set
them up for future success in life those
benefits are not available for students
students who cannot receive free or
reduced price lunches if they
qualify these bills and he's referencing
this bill as well the ones you'll hear
later today these bills would help
improve nutrition reduce food insecurity
enhance academic performance and remove
social stigma around students who need
to use this option families that are
able to take advantage of these programs
have incredible benefits HB 583 would
expedite the process of certifying
children on Medicaid for free or reduced
price meals removing the administrative
burden of completing multiple forms this
will not only help government or sorry
help students receive their meals more
quickly it provides for an easier
experience for parents and Guardians
meaning they spend less time processing
forms and more time playing with and
caring for their children overall
there's a lot of voter support for any
efforts to make it easier for kids to
get access to food I want to share those
sentiments thank you very much thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee yes represent papovich thank
you Mr chair and thank you for coming
here to testify
you spoke you know again about Hunger
being a significant issue and obviously
it is can you tell me if you aware of
any children being denied food at school
due to due to their inability to
pay I don't have specific data on that
it may come up uh later on when we speak
about the the bill regarding um stigma
around school debt um I know schools all
handle that problem in different ways
thank you further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
Arseno yeah just push the button yeah
okay got it good morning members of the
House committee on education funding my
name is Dr Christine arau I am a
pediatrician here in conquered with a
certification in nutrition and obesity
I'm also the vice president of the
American Academy of Pediatrics New
Hampshire chapter and a mother of three
young
children um I prepared a statement that
I sent to all of you um but I also
wanted to I just wanted to amend it a
little bit based on some of the things
that we've heard here today so I think
everyone in this room agrees that
children deserve access to nutritious
food so that they can learn and
Thrive um we've heard that there are
over 10,000 kids who qualify for
Medicaid which means means their parents
have submitted documentation that they
have a low
income who are not currently enrolled in
the reduced and free school lunch
program um M label spoke today so one
argument that I've heard is you know
well the school seems to feed these kids
so maybe maybe this isn't
necessary there is a huge stigma um for
families and
kids around poverty and food in security
um I will never forget the first
time I had a parent break down in tears
in my office she works full-time and
I've known her for years her husband
works nights they have three kids and
she said you know I don't I don't have
enough I don't have any food left I
don't know what to do
so this is a real problem for families
and many kids and many families are
hesitant to um this and therefore may
not go up and get the lunch from the
school cafeteria as M Lael said
um I find it troubling also to suggest
Alternatives you know um for the reduced
and free lunch
program you know such as maybe if we put
it online that will make it easier for
families I think that any suggest
question that perhaps we could miss some
of the
kids just is inherently troubling to me
because I think all of these kids have
demonstrated that they do not have or
their families have demonstrated that
they do not have very much money and
that should be enough to qualify them
for the free and reduced school lunch
program
um we have a lot of data showing that a
healthy breakfast and lunch improve
children's physical health improve their
behavior if you've ever spent time with
a hungry child you know that they are
not in the form to learn um
and having nutritious breakfast and
lunch at school also improves long-term
Health income outcomes including rates
of obesity and chronic disease um please
allow all kids the benefit a full belly
so that they can focus on learning vote
ought to pass on House Bill 583 thank
you thank you very much doctor uh are
there any questions from the
committee
yeah not seeing thank you very much
thank you very much uh I do not have any
do we have somebody from the Department
of Education here who can tell us what
the income I do have some questions for
the Department that
are policy oriented like HHS is involved
here with Medicaid how is that
confidential information released from
that department to doe so we know that
we have these students we know we have
tanif and snap um that was supposed to
been resolved the last time we discussed
that bill I just like like to know if
there's been a process that's been
resolved where a parent can check off
the box when they're applying for that
with HHS and that how that information
then gets
to the other
department so specifically my question
was I was looking for just a chart that
tells us what the income limits are for
both of the
programs we can testify to that okay we
got it right here then thank you very
for okay I asked the public to try to
get those all to us because we're trying
to
gauge around the schedule that we have
and these late cards
sometimes from We're from New Hampshire
hunger Solutions I'm Laura milikin I'm
the executive director riona deputy
director I oversee the Child Nutrition
work in New Hampshire so and and we held
our cards because we did not want to say
things that other people said so we're
just going to fill in a couple of things
starting with the eligibility for free
meals is at
130% of the federal poverty level and
the eligibility for reduced meals is at
level I think it's worth um pointing out
why there are more children on Medicaid
than there are on free and reduced meals
uh children are often signed up at their
first well child visit if they don't
have health insurance um and uh many
more families uh feel less stigma around
Medicaid than they do around the free
and reduced meal program that doesn't
mean that their their um families are
any less living in need uh it means that
that they're willing to give information
to get their child health insurance um
and for whatever reason they uh can't or
don't want to sign up for free and
reduced meals and um it doesn't mean
insecure hello um so another point that
I wanted to just state is that we
understand that there are a lot of
families who do decide to bring uh pack
their child's meal some of my work is to
work directly with schools to increase
that snap direct certification as well
as increase participation in school
meals we do know that the school meal
this meals served at school breakfast
and lunch um they are nutrition packed
for the child so if the child is eating
those two meals they have the accurate
nutrition to learn and grow and they
also
um can be offered other items in if the
district qualifies for dinner as well uh
free fresh fruits and vegetables um we
also o do a lot of work with the
business administrators and last year I
had 15 schools I worked with directly
this year 40 schools so our work at
Hunger Solutions is getting larger the
number one thing is the direct
certification it streamlines the process
for administrators as well as the
parents it's efficient effective and it
overall I'd also like to address um
representative papuchi mller's uh
question about why we don't data on
exactly how many uh kids in New
Hampshire are hungry at school or who's
being turned away it's just not possible
to collect the data because it would
require children to ask for a meal that
they know they can't pay for if families
aren't eligible for free and reduced
price meals because of the income limits
the parents aren't telling their
children to ask for meals um our public
schools are should not be places where
children living in low-income families
should go hungry or experience feeling
of of Shame and stigma and that's why we
have to improve how we provide School
meals um and Medicaid direct
certification would J us
that the data we do have shows a
significant disparity between children
participating in lunch where everyone
eats and no one knows who's paying full
price for lunch and breakfast which is
often very stigmatizing it's considered
um you know free breakfast for poor kids
um and so um and and also um the
comparisons of data that we have during
the pandemic when everybody was eating
and then what happened after the
pandemic is also telling people uh not
just um low-income families but middle
inome families are struggling to make
ends meet so um this bill though would
not raise eligibility in any way this is
just uh finding the kids and giving them
the ability to eat their families can
still say no we don't want to eat that
there's no part of this that requires
children to
eat thank you very much are there
questions from the
committee yes represent Damon thank you
um this may have been stated at the very
beginning of the hearing I was in
another
hearing but in case not um can you share
with us how many other states are
already enrolled in Medicaid direct
certification yes there are
43 other
states um f further question
represent
fellows yes can you tell us tell me the
income measure that Medicaid uses so you
you told us free and reduced oh so um so
this bill would only certify the
children on Medicaid who are eligible
for free and reduced meals so those are
the income limits that are that would be
applied so again 100 and and 100 30% for
free up to 130% and up to 185% for
reduced so Medicaid does cover children
at much higher incomes but those
children would not be affected by that
this
bill represent
papovich thank you very much Mr chair
and welcome back I know that we had some
good discussions two years ago or one
year ago um the question I wanted to
clarify was not about an extensive study
about the number of children that maybe
denied my question is literally if you
are aware of one child at one school
being denied one meal ever due to their
inability to pay I understand the
complexity of getting complex data and
the doe was supposed to gather some
information my question about one one1
yes there are I do know there I'm not
going to list those schools because we
are working directly with them to help
that but there are and specifically
older children high school children are
denied the food or um given an
alternative Meal which is different than
everyone else in the school Mr chair I
just want to follow up very briefly
could you please share that information
with the entire committee thank
you any further
questions thank you very much for coming
oconnell uh chairman lad members of the
committee um thank you for having this
hearing and allowing us to speak today
um so I'm uh speaking in support of this
bill um I know that uh a submission has
been made under the vice chair of the
Manchester Board of school committee and
we have submitted a letter in writing
and support of the bill um I just have a
couple of things to uh say I wasn't here
I apologize being late getting here so I
know you don't want people to be
repetitive so it's hard to avoid that
when I don't know everything was said so
I'll be brief um you know to me this is
is is a should be a very simple thing
first of all it's a bipartisan or
nonpartisan issue we look at the states
that have already implemented this they
vary from States like New York and
California and uh and Pennsylvania
states like West Virginia and Kentucky
um so and and as we just heard 43 states
are doing it I would just like to point
out the the there are significant
numbers of kids who who end up not
getting are not qualifying for free in
reduced lunch because the paperwork
isn't submitted and that was exasperated
because of it changes during covid when
the federal government allowed um
everybody to have free roduced lunch and
so people get out of the habit of it uh
and that's that's exasperated the
problem but you know from the point of
view of good governance and lean govern
governing and saving money and doing you
know in the city of Manchester we start
every year with a number of kid
percentage of kids on freedom roduced
lunch and it rises throughout the year
it doesn't rise because there are more
children coming who are hungry it rises
because efforts are made all day long to
try to get people to submit paperwork
and in the city of Manchester that
amounts we're right right now I don't
have the exact number but it's just
above 50% and that that historically is
a little under where it wasi prior to co
but let's just take the 50% number that
represents about 6,000 children and
while they don't all come one at a time
some of them might have you know two or
three from a family but it's 6,000
people pieces of paperwork that have to
be uh have to be written up there has to
be entered there data entry has to be
done and you know you do 100 a week you
that takes you more than a year maybe
you should be doing many more than 100 a
week but it's a real issue so it would
it would actually make things much more
simple administratively and safe costs
for the city of Manchester I don't know
if they'd be huge costs but there's a
cost saving there's work involved in
handling paperwork um frankly the the
more compelling reason is that we have
we have children in the city of
Manchester and we know in the state of
New Hampshire who uh are hungry who come
to school hungry and that's one of the
basics need needs that must be met
before they're in a position to learn
and this is an easy I if you forgive me
for putting it like this to commit I
think this should be an easy yes because
of the benefits that acrew from H from
from having this bill and and the the
lack of negatives so I'd encourage you
I'll stop there because I don't want to
repeat what other people have said but
thank you again for your time today and
I'd be happy to take any questions if
you have
any thank you for coming up are there
any questions from the
committee not seeing you thank you very
Rihanna that's that's we did did it okay
that goes with the firewor on Hunger
morning Mr chairman good morning I'm
sorry I was absent I was things down
where oh good good yeah I was just off
with the Senate education committee they
have a fascinating Bill there um but I
and I I know you've heard all about how
many children this would affect and how
important it is and but this being the
education committee I just wanted to
make sure that you had lots of data on
the educational impacts of being hung R
and I would reference you to a really
good report by feeding America it's
called child food insecurity the
economic impact on our nation it's a
long report but some of the highlights
of it they talk about uh math and
reading scores between kindergarten and
third grade children who have food
security gain 84 points and those who
don't only gain 73 points so it's a
significant uh loss there there are
twice children who are food insecure in
classif ifed as hungry are twice as
likely as those who are not hungry to
receive special ed services and twice as
likely to repeat a grade so if you're
looking if if one of the hesitations is
well this is going to increase the
number of students who get the free and
reduced launch amount under the base
adequacy plus differentiated Aid it's
going to cost the school money if
children are accurately fed they will
not need as much special ed services
they won't need to repe repeat grades
that would save the state money
uh the study also talks about how um
school-aged children who are hungry and
at risk for Hunger or more likely to
have problems with hyperactivity
absenteeism generally poor behavior and
academic functioning than they not
hungry Fe peers so all of those things
are going into perhaps the need for
additional services in the school or the
need for Paras food insecure children
are twice as likely to have been
suspended from school that has a
tremendous impact on educational
outcomes and four times as likely to
have history of needing mental health
counseling and there's a lot more in
here where they document how all these
things will save the state money but I'm
just saying if if if your concern is
finances feeding the children and you're
looking at all these education bills if
we spend money and this that or the
other thing this has got to be one of
the best cost benefit analysis that you
can get hungry children perform well
imagine coming to the legislature and
being here for testimony for six or
eight hours today not having had
breakfast not having had lunch by the
afternoon you would not be able to pay
attention how can children be expected
to pay attention if they aren't
adequately fed I guess the last thing is
the governor has said that as a state we
have to operate like a family and we
have to maintain within our family
budget if we are now looking at the
state government as a family the people
of New Hampshire as a family the very
last thing we're going to do if we're
good parents is have Starving Children
sitting in school all day so if we
really are a family we should feed the
children thank you thank you David are
there any question question for
him yes thank you thank you David um can
you tell me the name you read it really
quick I got the child food insecurity
yes it's called the child food
insecurity the economic impact on our
nation by Dr John Cook he's the Project
Director in the organization that's
called feeding
America thank you welcome thank you very
much further questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
and with that I'm going to close the
hearing for 583 the next that we have is
coming up after lunch at 1:00 which will
be
you yeah yeah well the questions
we
e
I
know I don't know his schedule and what
other committees he may be on I know
and okay I'd like to go ahead and
commence with our afternoon hearings
here the first bill up is 646 but prior
to that just like to make a a note to
the folks right here on the committee
that today we did vacate the local EFA
Bill to
education Administration or the
education policy side of thing so that's
been vacated seeing many of the issues
in that were policy oriented issues
dealing with local not necessarily our
state money um so so that's HP 748
yeah well you're
back uh representative you're welcome uh
torski uh 646 is requiring school
districts to establish an online
application for participation in the
free and reduced price meal
program welcome thank you very much
welcome back thank you for having me
again I hope everyone had a
restful and rejuvenating lunch to tackle
the afternoon and that's exactly what I
want for all students here in the
granite state um I first want to bring
your attention to a letter of testimony
that I um have distributed around um
from the Reverend Wells from the St
Matthews Church in gtown he actually
speaks to four different um anti-hunger
bills so I am passing that around now
and I hope you can consider it consider
it in your deliberations uh again I am
representative lur lki from Hillsboro 11
which is nasha's w 8 and I'm pleased to
introduce to the committee House Bill
646 that would require districts to
establish an on online application for
participation in the free and reduced
meal program earlier today we all heard
a lot of testimony on the importance of
the national school lunch program when
discussing the Medicaid direct
certification bill so I won't rehash
that information but just to establish a
baseline both surveys and data point to
real food in security here in the state
the school meals program is a vital tool
to tackling childhood hunger by
providing a meal and in many districts
two meals to kids living in poverty
children benefit from school Meals by
being able to focus on learning have
better academic outcomes and grow into
healthy well adjusted contributing
members of our community additionally we
know that there are students in poverty
over 10,000 of them who are eligible for
the program based on their family income
but are not yet enrolled this bill House
Bill 646 is another attempt to identify
these children by offering families an
easier more convenient online
application for enrolling for schools
online applications reduce
administrative burdens of processing
stacks of paper streamlines the process
with reduced errors and results in a
much timer verification process
enrolling the kids more quickly I think
we all remember as students ourselves or
as parents the paper forms from the meal
program that would come home in
September in a backpack the form would
hopefully make it home parents would
fill it out put it back in the backpack
and if all went well it would make the
return trip to the classroom the office
and eventually make it to the food
service department often the forms would
be lost in transit or simply not
returned at all and in today's world
with all kinds of Technology there are
still schools who run their program this
way the alternative is an application
that goes live in mid August before the
school year even begins parents receive
an email and they can fill out the
income information in the privacy of
their home without being concerned about
who may see that information if it was
handwritten on a paper and passed back
into the classroom the information is
then received promptly and verified by
the district and the child can be
registered for meals right away the city
of nasua has utilized an online
application for about 10 years now and
speaking with the food service director
there I learned that the electronic
application can be verified in 24 to 48
hours after the parent submit submits it
paper forms on the other hand can take
up to 10 days if not longer to actually
make their way into the district and to
get the child certified into the
program during this time that child's
not in the program they could
potentially be eating meals they could
be acre meal debt so enrollment in the
program which is not
backdated um time is is a factor that's
very important because even if the
family is enrolled they don't get
reimbursements for those other meals
that were eaten before they were
enrolled so privacy and confidentiality
is a big benefit to moving to an
electronic format some parents May fear
the stigma their child may experience
carrying that form in but an online
application directly submits the
information to the one person who needs
it the district employee responsible for
the
verification for School Employees the
work involved with tracking collecting
and processing these paper forms is
extremely burdensome and the amount of
work that staff have to dedicate to the
process is significant an online
application takes that burden away
freeing them up to focus on more
important tasks in fact schools that
have online applications like NASA
report that it makes the entire process
easier for both families and the
districts and online applications have
far fewer errors and mistakes than the
inefficient handwritten forms that can
often result in rejections that need to
then be tracked down and followed up and
information um replaced and
resubmitted some other benefits to an
automated form you can have an online
platform with a very userfriendly design
and tools that guide the family through
the process to fill out the form the
form can be provided in multiple
languages to reach families that have a
language barrier in nashaa their online
form has links to Spanish and Portuguese
forms but there's also a link to the
paper forms to the USDA where there are
51 different languages uh with the form
available for families an online form is
friendlier for those with disabilities
who may struggle in completing a paper
form and finally parents can apply for
the program throughout the year it's not
a one-time only application so having
that online form available allows
families to be able to apply throughout
the year if they have a change in their
uh job situation or a change in their
household and it allows them to easily
apply midyear if needed House Bill 646
would require that districts offer an
online application in addition to the
physical paper form which is required by
the USDA and that paper form will still
be made available for those that need it
for example maybe grandparents who are
raising grandchildren who are more
comfortable with the paper form or
families who don't have access to the
technology of a computer um or email but
either way those paper forms will still
still be made
available while there is no fiscal note
yet I did receive some initial feedback
um that it could potentially require a
position for assisting districts so
there's an appropriation for that as
well as funds to assist districts in
fulfilling this requirement I'll wrap
this up by saying that this bill is also
about efficiency for both families and
school districts we know that there's a
disconnect and a challenge for families
to enroll in school meals and providing
easy and confidential online option to
apply for from home just makes sense
shifting to an online application
reduces the intense work associated with
paper forms and takes the burden off the
school staff and gets meals in front of
those kids sooner so I thank you for
your time Mr chairman and I hope you
consider this Bill thank you very much
are there any questions for the sponsor
your refer person McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question so why is any money
here necessary couldn't uh NASA share
the software that they developed via the
school boards Association or something
like that and other people just use it
well that's maybe something that someone
behind me could address but um we don't
have a whole lot of information on which
districts actually have the program and
a number of districts maybe use a
different parent portal so um initially
my thought process on the funds that
were um associated with this was to not
have it be an unfunded mandate on local
districts and to help them in providing
this format um but I'm not exactly sure
if there is a uh one-size fits all that
exists right now that can then be plug
and play in every
District further question represent yes
papovich thank you very much Mr chair
and thank you representative for
testifying and taking
questions I agree that there are a lot
of school districts and can be very
difficult to uh accommodate the needs of
each of one of them individually have
you considered when preparing this
legislation the possibility of just
asking the doe to have a form process
the applications and then just pass the
data down to the schools it seems to be
a slightly less bantine approach than
hundreds of individual districts with
their own forms thank you for the
question um from what I understand the
Department of Education is barred from
collecting the forms at the state level
um and it has to go straight to the
districts uh meaning that one
application at the state level is not
possible but hopefully there'll be
someone here that could verify that Mr
chair follow up yes thank you for
telling me that I was not aware of it
under the circumstances though would it
be still possible for the district doe
to maintain that portal and just have
the data go directly to the district I'm
just trying to think around you know to
see if we consider the possibility of
aoid again hundreds of individual
districts doing repetitive work that
maybe could be done better in one place
thank you thank you for the question I
think that is a great idea um the
possibilities of that I believe are
somewhat endless to try to make
everything more efficient and I would be
interested in exploring it more um no I
did not I was not able to dig deeply
into that those Solutions but thank you
for the
question thank you further
questions don't see anything thank you
very much thank you so much I appreciate
it the next card is
kuger any more reps that's it no right
here good afternoon I'm representative
kuger from nashille ward
3 I'm speaking to you today in support
of HB
646 providing an online option for free
and red uced lunch is a necessary and
valuable bill that addresses food
insecurity not only are online forms
more efficient for administrative staff
they narrow the risk of important
paperwork being lost or
compromised the transporting of free
reduced lunch applications by students
can result in missed deadlines and
ultimately with it the Lost opportunity
for
lunch as a former educator I contend
that students need adequate food within
their school day moreover food security
promotes academic
success I do know firsthand what it's
like to witness kids who are hungry in
school I also know that these breakfast
and lunches can very well be the only
food students receive in their
day we can't take the risk that children
miss this possibility for food
security I ask you to support HB
646 and be advocates for the success of
our students thank you you're welcome
are there any questions from the
committee now see you thank you very
good morning everyone um or good
afternoon sorry um my name is
representative Christine cybert um from
Hillsboro district 21 which is
Manchester's Ward one um so I come
before you today I I want to thank you
all um for being here um as a result of
implement I want to talk first about
Manchester's um experience with this
as a result of implementing the online
application program in Manchester we can
proudly say that more students are able
to apply and receive fnr
meals or apply for sorry this offers a
better option of an entry point for
families to apply for the program it
results in a more accurate count of
students that qualify for fnr in turn
this provides additional funding for
districts to support some of our most
vulnerable students if you see the
attack fcal note the cost of this
program in Manchester for example
through my school apps is between $1,000
to $2,000 annually the and the my school
apps I think is one of the portals that
we were just talking about um with one
of with the bill sponsor and I counted I
actually went on there to try to do it
myself um just to kind of you know start
the application process to kind of just
see what it was like and there's about
20 School option or School District
options on there so the there's about 20
in that particular using that particular
portal
program um and so when the my school
apps walks one through the application
as they are filling it out making the
process easier to understand it also
provides explanations about the proper
paperwork required to fill out the form
more importantly this process provides
the ability to submit an application at
any time through the school year if
there is a sudden loss of income we
currently have 20 school districts that
provide the online application for this
program yet the f&r program is used
Statewide while these numbers might vary
and change from time to time we cannot
forget the interconnectivity of every
Community Andor region in New Hampshire
if a major employer in an area lays off
a lot of the workforce natural disaster
hits or other sudden and unexpected
circumstances people there will need
will be need for this to be
available I don't know about the rest of
this body but I do not want to be the
last state in the nation that has
implemented all of the tools that are
available to end childhood hunger we
hear over and over again the arguments
against supporting legislation based on
religious beliefs I cannot help myself
but to ask where your religious morals
and values are when it comes to our
ability to work together and pass
legislation that the teachings of Jesus
directly compels his followers to
support
please see the following page for the
full list of reasons why you should
support HB
646 any question thank you very much any
questions yes representative fellows
thank you Mr chair um thank you for
testifying yeah do you um when you were
using it did you see anything that might
suggest that I you can read the form in
different
languages there was on the option to
pull up like a the like um Laura was
mentioning where it it was alongside
that area though where you can pull up
the USDA form and it had it in just
multiple languages so the Manchester one
has it in I believe about two
languages so thank you further
questions not seeing thank you very much
hello
again um I'm still Megan brck with save
the children Action Network um from New
Market New Hampshire I shared earlier
today voter views on the government's
role in addressing hunger and the
intensity with which they view this
problem so I will not reiterate those
points um I wanted to just address two
other items um first being uh the issue
of whether students are being turned
away for for lunches sort of insinuating
the need do we need to enroll more
students in the free and reduced um
meals
program not all schools are necessarily
turning students away who are hungry
right whether or not they're enrolled um
but in those situations they're eating
that cost so by getting all the students
who are eligible for the program
enrolled in the program these schools
are able to um pass over having to make
the decision themselves about how to
feed those kids and Access Federal
reimbursement I think that's a very
important uh point for us to keep in
mind that we're accessing federal
dollars that um we're entitled to in our
state and bringing those to New
Hampshire
citizens um I also want to once again
share a statement from one of our
Advocates uh we have a lot of Advocates
of save the children Action Network one
of our Advocates Ben Buckley of New
Market shared the following with
me HB 646 would allow parents and
Guardians with an internet connection to
apply online being able to complete
necessary forms online is a huge benefit
that many Granite State residents are
able to enjoy and it should be the same
for those needing free or reduced price
launches saving time saves money and
energy that can be used elsewhere
whether it be with their dependents or
local businesses in their Community like
other New Hampshire residents I want our
students to find success in school go to
college or a trade school and get good
jobs so that they may provide for
themselves and their families in the
future providing free or reduced price
lunches to students who need them will
ensure that they have a bright future I
urge you to pass these bills and give
the Next Generation the opportunity to
realize their potential end quote uh
this is a common sense measure to close
the gap between those who are eligible
for meals and those who are enrolled in
the program thank you thank you very
committee not seeing any thank you very
much uh next person
kuger all
right good afternoon everyone thank you
Mr chairman um I'll be quick with you
guys but uh I support HB 646 and
understand the importance of this bill
not all that many years ago I was a high
school student who witnessed food
insecurity every day I made the decision
to help another student who didn't have
food or the money to buy in
school I bought extra food and lunches
to help him out my parents noticed my
lunch account was being deleted faster
than it should have of course I had to
tell them what was what I was doing my
mom said exactly what I knew she would
why isn't the lunch being
provided the truth is the student didn't
tell anyone and was likely embarrassed
although I never asked is entirely
possible that the free lunch form wasn't
handed in no high school kid is going to
share that of course not I continued to
buy the lunches and was happy to do it I
can only imagine how a student must have
felt though so let's work together to
fight food insecurity and be Cent that
we've exercised all of our options so
please support HB 646 thank you what a
nice student appreciate it thank you uh
any any questions from the
committee yes R Damon thank you Mr chair
thank you for coming and sharing with us
I wonder if you could surmise what would
have happened if your friend didn't have
a friend with the resources to help feed
them that that's a good question I think
I hope someone would have helped him as
well but I he might not have he would
just either not eating lunch I guess
because I know he was a athlete as well
so going hungry well practicing football
would not have been a good idea for him
um so I guess he's just very fortunate
that uh he got to know me so that's a
good question I don't think who knows
it's a good wh if question no system
that you were aware of no yeah there was
nothing yeah thanks further
questions not any thank you very much
awesome than for sharing have a good day
tibo good after good afternoon can you
hear me yes we can thank
you um thank you for having me my name
is Cynthia tibo and I'm the mckin vento
homeless leison for the dairy School
District as you may know uh mckin vento
assistance Act is a federal program and
it was created in 1987 and was named
after two Congressional um
Representatives who are strong
supporters Stuart mckin and Bruce fento
the aim was to offer assistance to
homeless children in the areas of food
transportation and access to
school um my V mckin vento form Works a
little bit differently than the regular
um way of getting assistance for food um
they come in the parents make an
appointment with me I determine through
a series of questions if they qualify
for mckin vento and then um after they
fill out the form I call the um food
service director directly and I tell
them who is going to be um on her list
for Kento for the year so it's like
right uh right um that day immediately
they'll know who who is to be added onto
the list for the next day and those
children will get a card just like any
other student so that they aren't
singled out for um their need for
food
um and the top of it that says relative
to so I have a lot of information
relative to this is as far as our topic
today is concerned the USDA recommends
two servings of fruit and three
vegetables per day a homeless child may
be offered a fruit and a vegetable with
their meal while at school and did you
know that salsa is considered a
vegetable under the federal
guidelines it is difficult for homeless
parents to afford fresh fruits and
vegetables nor is there a place usually
to prepare food fresh canned or Frozen
and Families are living in a f friend's
basement in a motel in a shelter or
maybe on Grandma's floor so food
preparation is difficult it might limit
a child's intake of the recommended
Foods children enjoy raw carrots and
celery though celery doesn't contain
many
nutrients another thing is that families
and shelters must be out by 6:30 to 7:00
a.m. in the morning often with the
mother with the baby in her arms and the
toddler and toe and most mothers don't
have have access to a car or a computer
to fill out a form they often come to me
to you know fill out the forms and very
few of them have strollers to walk the
children to the grocery store or to a
place where they could access um
computer hookups to fill out
forms chances of obtaining fresh produce
is nil many schools in New Hampshire
provide 68 hours of hunger which is a
program that packs bags of non-
perishable items for the weekend
and it usually consists of granola bars
and mac and cheese and pasta and similar
items and while it is a wonderful
program that keeps families afloat
through the weekend the children are
still not eating their vital nutrients
they're still not available to them in
the afternoons or on the
weekends some schools will put out bowls
of fresh fruit in a common area such as
the library so children may help
themselves during the day apples bananas
and oranges are among the favorites
however not all schools are able to do
this another snag in the 68 hours of
hunger in our in our food program
overall is that older children usually
starting with grades four and up will
refuse to take a bag of food because
they are immediately identified by their
peers as needy and there is a stigma
regarding homelessness and the children
are embarrassed by taking home the
donation
bag finally the infants and toddlers are
also included under the mckin vento act
and under this umbrella donations of
formula are rare since it is so
expensive you know people don't mind
buying a couple of boxes of spaghetti
but when they're looking at the cost of
a can of formula it's you know a lot
different it's very expensive as far as
donations go so think about how a
homeless mom would feel who can't afford
the for formula and she has already
watered down what she does have
also one more snag is that if the
formula or the baby food that is donated
it's not often the right kind or it's
not appropriate for the child's
age and do you have any questions thank
you thank you very much any questions
represent fellows um yes I'm just
wondering if you could share your
perspective on how many of the people
that you deal with would be capable of
filling out the form on their own or do
they need help I'm just trying to figure
out what percentage of the people I not
able to fill out the form thank you I
have about um 35 to 40 homeless families
during the year and um I would say maybe
2third of them are equipped to fill it
out and the other ones are not really
assistance go ahead
if they had it on paper or would they
still need assistance probably
okay further
questions I got one question for you
mcken vento where I've been has been
administered by the
municipality and is there uh a line of
communications that you had directly uh
working with the school districts to
inform them we have these homeless
children or the homeless families or
needy families I work directly in the
superintendent's office and I have
another cohort that works at Pinkerton
who handles the high school students and
I work with um K through 8 and I also if
they have um toddlers or babies I also
help out with that and then Kevin
McGrath at Pinkerton helps out with the
um uh you know freshman through senior
thank you very much you're welcome are
there further
questions thank you thank you
uh next card is
Rihanna um sarin Karen sarin yeah I know
you've
been New Hampshire hunger Hunger riona
core yes New Hampshire hunger Solutions
thank you
representative I'm here on behalf of New
Hampshire hunger Solutions we are a
nonpartisan um advocacy group in New
Hampshire across the street uh we
located in conquer and I oversee the
Child Nutrition portion of our work uh
currently I have 40 schools that I work
with directly um face to face as well I
travel across the street ac across the
state um to talk at Council meetings I
also go to school Wellness committee
meetings anyone who needs the
understanding of uh free and reduced
meal applications related to their
school meal budget out of all of the
schools that I oversee all of them have
some sort of alternate feeding process
for their children that may be that the
teachers and the administrators are
keeping a drawer that they purchase
items for their students who are hungry
that come that come in I also H do some
food pantry work and I have an
outpouring of schools that are asking
for food pantries in their schools with
this being said I know there's a lot of
solutions to end Hunger in the children
this is just one system change that can
help at um increase the access for
individuals and streamline the process
for those administrators who are working
with free and reduceed meal applications
um it it's way more efficient like Laura
tki mentioned we also uh want to state
that it's confidential I do have three
children at home as well age range from
5 to 11 my middle schooler will not
bring papers home I don't know where
they go um the free reduced mail
application has been sent with him I
don't receive it it's a crumpled up ball
somewhere I don't think I'm going to
send my personal information in with my
middle schooler and it's really hard to
send that information with my
kindergartener um the stigma around the
free reduced mail applic ation is very
high that child is unlabeled as free and
reduced and I don't want my children to
voice um it also eliminates those errors
like we mentioned with translation
services all the browsers now that are
used if the online application is there
I'm just going to mention that there are
some browsers that you can click to
translate specifically Google translate
anything that is on the um web browser
so there are other options for
translation services and individuals can
do it from their phone uh there was
uh also mentioned in some of our
research that majority of individuals do
have cell phones so that is something
that they can do in the privacy of their
home or just outside with our work we
also like to give signs to schools we
have signage to snap and also free and
reduce mail applications outside of 10
schools right now with this in the
pickup and drop off line parents can
snap the QR code on the sign and sign up
for free and reduce meals and we saw an
increase in one of the C Co schools of
of the applications which reduced their
March 2024 School mail debt from over
$1,000 to $343 just by online
applications and um not to mention
everything else that has said today but
I would be open for questions thank you
very much are there any questions
represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair and
thanks for joining us this afternoon um
could could you Rihanna could you talk a
little bit about um maybe the um the
number of families uh that this would
help out particularly you know in light
of the the the comments you made
surrounding the or like with respect to
the stigma surrounding the um the the
paper um application stigma is very big
with with the application itself it is
put into a usually a folder and sent
home um to a parent to try to figure out
and if you've seen it is all online if
you go to the USDA website or even
Department of Education that application
is there just it's daunting to look at
um it hasn't been updated and we have to
stick to those strict guidelines
although the online application is
straightforward there are some schools
that do have this within those apps that
um another school representative
mentioned such as link and it is four
question boxes and it can approve or
deny or say there's an error so that
process of stating there's an error
happens right then in place rather than
having the application sent in with your
kindergarten or your middle schooler and
then being say being sent back saying
you need to redo this so that error is
is point in time fixed right with the
online
application thank you further questions
thank you thank you very much
Rihanna um that we have Becky Wilson do
you have anything you wanted to
communicate are you just here for
Technical Support I'm just here for
technical support and perhaps if someone
from yeah that's my next one I'm happy
to
come okay is the department does the
department have any information for us
on this are there any committee members
would like to ask a technical question
of the department so we do have one
good afternoon my name is Kelly Rambo
I'm the bureau administrator for the
wellness and nutrition um Bureau at the
department Melissa white division
director for learner support at New
Hampshire Department of Education
so do we have a a question do you have
any technical information you like to
impart or would you like to just take
the questions um I think that we have
provided everything um in the fiscal
note so we'll be happy to take um any
questions okay there were some questions
uh represent
luno thank you very much Mr chair thanks
for being here here this afternoon and
for taking um some technical questions
um I want to sort of drill into the
fiscal note a little bit um it says down
here software indeterminable up to a
million and then software million
dollars for the bayum ending um June
30th 2027 just wondering where the
million bucks came from given the fact
that that the Department of Education
created a software platform so that
every High School graduating senior can
take a a dubiously um you
know effective immigration and
naturalization test exam uh as a
graduation requirement and the
department was able to create that
software platform for half million
dollars is what we heard last week so
I'm wondering why this one cost so much
more sure thank you for the question um
I'd be happy to answer that um so the
fiscal note is related to at the the
local level um so due to the RSA 189 um
68 for student privacy we are unable to
have that application at a state level
so the fiscal note is related to that
dollar amount is related to the local
level um and currently right now um as
testified before there are different um
data platforms that each local level has
um so we we don't currently have the
information on what particular data
platforms that each local level has um
so it's indeterminable for us to to know
how much that cost would be some might
use um my school meal apps some might
use another platform so there's
different prices that are associated
with that so that's where that number is
coming from
follow yes so so thanks for that but but
you know I thought that um that that
basically went for instance with the
with the paper forms that those were
filled out and collected locally and
then information was transmitted to the
department so that so that it that some
sort of connection with
USDA guidelines and so that it was still
managed through through the State and so
I'm wondering why why that couldn't be
done here since it appears to be that
way with the paper form sure thank you
for the question um that's aggregate
data that we're getting from the um from
the local levels on that that's not
family income information um and all of
the other items that are listed in um
that specific RSA related to student
privacy that we cannot collect at the
state level okay thank you further
questions no any other further questions
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you following
up on rep representative luno
questioning so is the million dooll uh
projected expense for software based on
needing to provide software for every
single School
District thank you for the question um
that is what we were going if we we had
to give a um some sort of dollar amount
and we don't know those districts that
currently have that so we that is
exactly um what we were um giving a
dollar amount on assuming that districts
do not currently have it they would need
some sort of startup cost um for that um
additionally there are um yearly
maintenance costs um that schools might
need in order to um continue the the
application process as well too to make
whatever upgrades that that might come
from um from a USDA standpoint or even
just data um
is it correct however based on what you
just informed us and that we have
already heard and know that there are a
number of schools perhaps many who do
already have online applications so
those schools presumably have a software
system so this number is the estimate if
you were creating an entirely a system
for the entire
State and therefore this number is more
than what it would actually be in
practice that is correct we do not have
the data on those that currently have an
online application at the department
level can we ask you to get that data oh
sorry I what what she want to do is she
want to basically ask me and then I will
make that request to them sort of
thought L yeah so that would come after
this right here thank you yeah and so do
you have a follow-up question yes Mr
chair would you be able to request that
they
I heard the of how many districts have
online meal applications currently I I
got
it further questions represent Burton
this is a naive question but why do you
need a piece of legislation to improve
the systems you working at the
Department of Education and presumably
if this bill doesn't pass you won't be
able to do
it so the bill is requiring at the local
level for them to establish an online
application system it's not requiring
the Department of Education to establish
an online application system so each
School District having to establish
their own online application system
there's a variety of products out there
we cannot tell you what it's going to
cost for each one of them to establish
this online application system we were
asked to provide what could we
guesstimate an amount and we came up
with that million doll amount it could
be less it could be significantly more
we do not know because we are not able
to tell you how much it would cost for
each one to establish that okay well
thank
you represent pillows um I'm I'm
thinking that that this would be a
module a free and reduced module that's
inside a a larger system that's
collecting enrollment and grades and all
of that sort of thing do do you have any
inventory in the department about what
applic what kind of software is being
used to collect the student data that
they have to report already so they're
all using a different product right now
our student information system we have
switched to an alma system and so there
are some school districts that are using
the alma system some are using Power
School some are using Aspen they all
have a different product that they're
using those student Information Systems
sometimes they might have a module or a
component that's attached to that
student information system that allows
for the collection of those online
applications for free and reduced
determinations but some of them do not
so it's going to depend on which product
that school district is using whether
that module is available to to them what
the cost could be if not if that
particular um system didn't have that
ability to add on that then they would
be looking at a separate system so
that's why it's it's really variable
because there's so many different
there for and just to clarify but don't
have any inventory that tells you which
products are being used by which
districts no okay thank are there
further questions represent
Damon thank you Mr chair so USDA has a
model free and reduced price School Meal
web online I'm looking
at is the department using that in this
projection or have you used it at all
purposes thank you for the question um
so that particular um module online
would be called um a road map um let's
say on the pieces that you would need if
you are an it um vendor to be able to
build an online um application so
um it it doesn't NE it's not necessarily
saying you can take this and utilize
this in in all of your locations at no
cost it's just the road map on here are
the pieces that are required from
USDA that need to be in the application
and as a vendor you would be using that
in order to um to build the application
and there are um current um systems that
do have an application already built in
there um for that so that's modeled um
after
that thank you thank you further
questions
not seeing thank you very
much and with that I'm going to close
646 and we're going to go directly into
HB
703 HB 703 is relative prohibiting
School District from denying meals to
students with unpaid meal balances and
making an appropriation
committee thank you Mr chair for the
welcome and the
opportunity um for the record state
representative hope hope Damon Sullivan
County District 8 the nine towns of
Acworth langon lemster oan Washington
Springfield s my hometown of Cen and the
City of
Claremont where we want to feed
kids
so
HB 703 this is School Meal
day um is put
forward with
considerable concern about events that
occurred in the past
year um widely reported in both the
gtown school district and the Keane
School District but likely not unique to
those districts and I don't say that to
specifically um call out those districts
just that it highlighted a
concern um so the intent is to prohibit
school districts from denying meals to
students who have unpaid meal balances
and also although it does not say it at
the very beginning to require school
districts to
accept funding from organizations that
come forward and volunteer to help write
off school Mill debt and then thirdly
when that does not happen or if that
does not happen to require the
Department of Education to write off the
meal debt um
so I
would start by saying that we should not
be penalizing children who through no
fault of their own are poor and
consequently food
insecure for many kids School meals are
the bulk of their food intake in fact
last year in House Education committee
we heard from a school administrator who
testified that the hardest part of
closing school for snow days was his
recognition that many kids would be
hungry all day without the presence of
School meals in their
lives given the lowi income criteria for
free reduced meals and as we heard this
morning it's 130% of federal poverty
level to qualify for free School meals
it's 185% of federal poverty level to
qualify for reduced price School
meals those income levels are very very
low compared to the cost of supporting a
family today we all know that the price
of eggs and everything else in the
grocery store is more than it was two
years ago 5 years ago 10 years ago those
income levels have not been increased I
believe it's about 15 years don't quote
me exactly on that I meant to look that
up but they have not been increased
recently they do not correspond to
today's cost of living so there are many
students who don't qualify for fnr meals
even if they were
applying but are food insecure their
family resources are more
limited than needed to comfortably feed
the family and cover all the other costs
of
703 um the first part is not a cost it
is about making sure that we don't
stigmatize
kids I am the daughter of a school food
service director so I grew up with
School Meal discussions in my home most
of my life um I'm a dietitian I worked
all my career at helping people take
care of themselves including some work
with Hunger agencies and with people who
did not have enough
resources the idea that we would shame a
child by identifying them with a
different meal or a wristband or any way
kids are smart they know what's going on
they see who is being treated
differently in the lunch
line we need to make it very very clear
that that is not acceptable behavior and
so that's line five and six in the bill
you can't deny a meal to a student you
can't serve them an alternative meal
because they lack funds or have a meal
balance and further online 10 through
um no tokens no stickers no stamps no
putting their name on a list at the cash
register or the checkout
station that a probably very well-
intended and kind lunch person employee
is scrolling down the list to double
check whether Johnny is still on there
or not and all the kids around know that
Johnny's
poor I have not seen this next section
happen in New Hampshire but this is
modeled on North Dakota legislation and
other states and there are places where
schools have limited student
participation in any activities outside
of the basic academics if they have an
unpaid meal balance like they can't
participate in sports or the school play
or go on the field trip that's wrong and
when we pass 703 that won't
happen um and further we cannot require
schools to work off their meal
debt this is not the 1940s or
1850s this is today and we don't have
child labor or we shouldn't to collect
the trash through the school or
something similar to work off meal debt
um the bill does require that schools
develop an Outreach plan to encourage
parents or Guardians to apply for the
f&r lunch program uh meal program and as
other bills today have addressed there
are a number of ways we could improve
how we do that it also proh prohibits
the school district from using a
collections agency to collect unpaid
School Mill debt and when this bill
passes that won't be necessary because
we will be providing for
it and I mentioned the voluntary
donations okay so
then
um I am going to acknowledge that I have
not prioritized adequate amount of time
on this fiscal note and quite frankly
it's troubling to me um I think there
will be further discussion and a revised
one presented to you because the numbers
seem to be based on the total number of
meals breakfast and lunch that are not
fully paid by the federal government or
existing programs well lots of those
meals are paid for by families not
everyone's food insecure so I don't
think the conclusion in here is valid
but respect to those who did it and I
have not yet talked to them so I
apologize for not having that um clear
at the outset um with that I will just
say that I can't imagine what it is to
be a hungry child and actually try to
behave and learn so I appreciate your
support and hope we can work through
this to make it better thank you very
much are there questions of the
representative yes representative
papovich thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for testifying and answering
questions could you address the um need
for uh one Roman numeral 8h which
authorizes the schools to complete the
application for free meals for the
on line 20 thank you for your question
26 yes thank you um So currently schools
are not permitted to complete the
application other than by assisting the
parents this would authorize schools if
they have the valid information to be
able to fill out that form to apply for
the
fnr yes thank you and this is the only
followup I'll save the rest for work
session um how would they get that
information if the parent didn't submit
an application I'm just trying to
understand the scenario in which this
will be useful and I'm done this is it
last question thank you it was fine um
that's a very good
question I don't honestly know I would
surmise which is a bit of a dangerous
thing to do that they have that
information from some other application
for some other program and I will find a
better answer to that before our work
session or a more certain answer are
there further questions represent
Manan thank you for allowing this
question thank you for taking my
question
um my my background is is high school
imagine the kid who ate his lunch when
he came to school in the morning uh and
he steps in line and goes to get a free
lunch um because he knows he's not going
to have to pay is there any recourse to
somebody like that who's actually just
using the
system thank you for the
question so if I'm understanding the
question you're presenting a student who
would not qualify for free and reduced
bills who's not in the
program just tell me that that wouldn't
be a given he he could be very well
qualified for the for the Freel launch
program it's just that if he's qualified
for the program why wouldn't he be
eligible to get the
lunch he's a high school kid and he's
hungry so he would he would go in and he
would take the lunch and without having
paid and and so I mean I just I see this
happening I mean I see it happening
anyway where where the kid knows the
system so I think representative that
you are suggesting that a hungry
student if this bill were to pass would
use this to get more food than they're
entitled to is that what you're asking
me I I'm wondering if the if the lunch
knowing the game would have a recourse
LGE the point of this bill is for Hungry
students to be fed so that they can then
learning further questions of the
committee yes representative fellows
thank you do you have any information on
which schools maybe do not participate
in the federal program because there
will be kids in those situations that
are maybe are not getting um fed and and
I assume this applies to Charter Schools
and
districts is that correct thank you for
the questions um
I don't off the top of my head have a
list of the schools in New Hampshire
that don't participate in the Federal
School meals program it's very short the
ones that I'm aware of in fact one is a
town in my own District Cen which is a
very very small K4 school that has less
than 30
students and they have found it's
actually not costeffective for them to
participate in the program um I can
certainly provide followup on other
schools but the vast majority of schools
in New Hampshire do participate in the
f&r school in the federal meals program
and your second question
was well as we know in our statutes if
it doesn't specify Charter Public School
then it doesn't cover Charter Public
School so in fact this does not apply to
them what I just said about the majority
of schools participating in the federal
meals program was in reference to
non-charter Public
Schools the charter schools are very and
I don't think I can accurately speak at
least not numerically but most of them I
fnr are there further questions from the
committee represent luno sure thanks
very much Mr chair and uh and thank you
for taking my question and for bringing
this forward so in a state that that
Allin spends north of $3.6 billion a
year on public schools is um is the f
note here um even even when you're sort
of
questioning does it seem like short
money compared to what we're currently
spending and uh and how improving
student
outcomes you know particularly among
students who are hungry um it it just
seems like um like like short money
given given what we're already putting
in thank you for the question and
emphatically yes this is a very small
investment for the outcomes that it
would provide we heard this morning and
I think many of us know from other
experiences and
learning that children who are wellfed
have less behavior issues have less
special education needs and costs
require less Staffing and succeed more
so in very casual terms it's a
no-brainer in the dollars and cents
compared to the rest of what we're
investing in
education thank you further questions
represent guire thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative is it possible
for parents to tell the school that they
don't want their children to be allowed
to have uh meals if they're trying to
help their child lose weight for
example yes I believe there is a
mechanism to do that however I will
respond to the second part of your
question that wasn't actually a question
it's actually very well documented that
students who receive School meals have
lower incidences of
obesity so if that were the reason why a
parent wants their child not to have
school meals it's not a valid reason not
that it's up to me to judge the parents
decision but it's not factual um but
there would be a way for them to not
participate yes no child has to get the
meal presently or with this
bill this is just addressing no shaming
and The Debt Service it's not about
requiring children to consume anything
further questions yes represent fellows
I'm just wondering if you've thought
about how to address the problem that
when parents find out that their kids
will get a meal even if let's say
they're not qualified for free and
reduced that if they know that their kid
will get a meal anyway even if they
don't pay for it what's to stop them
from just not paying anything and the
state ends up having to pay the whole
student I think that
that will happen to some
extent we would either accept that as
that student is fed and that is a good
thing that that student is fed for all
the reasons that have been
stated or I suppose a district could
decide to um communicate with the parent
about that
um I personally don't have language to
put in the bill to say how do you
penalize in that way I there there's no
program that doesn't have some person
who takes advantage of it but mostly
they wouldn't um thank you further
questions
thank you very much thank
you yes oh go
ahead thank you thank you for taking my
question
um just really quickly would this uh
Bill sorry would this bill um prohibit
the school district
from checking in with parents about an
unpaid
balance no
thank you in fact parents should I mean
districts
should um and most
do further
questions thank you very much thank you
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman um if I
may just to answer representative Fell's
initial question about the number of
schools that didn't have uh programs
last year it was 30 um when we did the
food meal study it was 30 however six of
those child schools actually did get
food meals from their public school but
has a separate contract um so once again
Mr chairman thank you for allowing me to
speak again uh today this on HP 703 I'm
only going to speak to the last part of
Representative Damon's Bill and that was
the PO was talking about the school meal
debt and I just want to take a couple of
minutes to touch few points from last
session uh while doing the research last
year on the at Ellison feed the damn
kids food bill we found that over 90
school districts last year had end of
school meal debt now I suggest that's a
small number because right now we know
including Charter Schools we have over
170 school districts in the
state as you know schools go out of the
way to make sure that each students have
something to eat the reality of which
means that each School creates an end of
school meal debt that is an additional
cost for local taxpayers for every
single town in city of New
Hampshire second this morning when you
heard testimony on Direct
certification I would suggest to you
that those students that are entitled
but not enrolled in the free and reduced
meal program are exactly the same
students we see in school in elementary
school the middle schools in the back of
the room hungry not eating and someone
says gez have you eaten today have you
eaten today those are the same
kids they the same kids from the most
needy families in New Hampshire and
whose schools are working to feed them
in essence this is just another example
of the state passing down more costs to
the local taxpayer if only
indirectly I'd request that this
committee reaffirm their commitment to
the needy of families and the hungry
students of the State of New Hampshire
by passing direct Ser by passing Line
application and financial aid to Local
School mail
debt this is a problem that can be
solved and this committee this committee
is the doorkeepers to the first step of
that solution thank you Mr chair thank
you are there any questions of
representa woodcock
not see you thank you very much thank
hansy which bill is this one oh that's
656 um we're on another bill right now
um which bill was that 656 yes that's
rebeck okay I'll take the 656 over here
hello G this is the last time you'll
have to hear from me today I promise um
I just wanted to address uh just a
couple more points here um the first I
wanted to share is actually more of a
personal reflection um in addition to
this being you know my line of work
advocating for kids issues here in New
Hampshire um I'm also the daughter of an
elementary school teacher my mother did
her student teaching in Chester and then
taught in Marlo New Hampshire for a
number of years before moving out of
state and if you folks are familiar with
that area that's a very rural Title One
school and um she is not alone in
sharing the story of bringing food to
her classroom knowing that kids are
going to
be not eating at lunchtime for whatever
reason um and are going to be hungry in
the afternoon and acting out and if she
wants to get through her curriculum she
needs to have snacks available in the
classroom um teachers cannot afford to
be holding up this system on their
salaries and we shouldn't be relying on
stop Gap measures like this and the
kindness of our Educators uh in lie of
uh fully fleshed out systems so that is
just one point I wanted to share um the
second I wanted to share um is just in
in response to um representative
Weinstein's question that this bill only
addresses the students experience in the
lunchroom um it the school can still can
attempt to collect from parents um my
understanding is that the schools can't
even take parents to court um so this is
not about you know allowing parents to
shk personal
responsibility um and and not have to
pay for these meals it's really just
about students not bearing the uh burden
of that in the meantime and them being
fed kind of regardless of what's going
on between the school and the parents so
I just wanted to clear those two things
up and then I once again have a
statement from our passionate Advocate
Ben Buckley of New Market HB 703 is a
critical component of removing social
stigma from those in need of those
programs while providing Public Schools
the funds they need to give these
students what they need it's been shown
that students who are consistently made
fun of or belied are at increased risk
for poor academic achievement according
to current research with this bill those
students uh taking advantage of this
program will not experience those issues
end quote so we all know that kids can't
learn if they're hungry we're all
passionate about making sure the Next
Generation has an education um I don't
think that's being debated here um so
the bill before you is a step to make
sure that you can take to make sure the
next generation is healthy and educated
um and once again I'll just reiterate
that voters want to see this
Administration take uh definitive action
to get kids fed thank you thank you very
much questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
core thank you Mr chairman again I hope
this is the last time you hear from me
today um thank you for the clarification
Megan I did want to state that this bill
is specifically about how kids are
treated in the lunchroom we do know that
a lot of the schools across the state of
New Hampshire are adapting the social
emotional well-being of the child into
their curriculums so this is something
that also goes on behalf of that the
child should not know the financial
situation of their parents if it is the
caregiver if it is the parent or
guardian or if they even even are in
foster care there um isn't a lot of
schools that I directly work with but
there has been schools that have turned
away children who do have negative meal
debt or also um serve them an alter
alternative Meal which is not what the
other children are receiving so this
bill specifically is to not shaming the
shame the CH to not shame that child who
is going through that meal line and um
and to protect the child within a safe
School
environment uh how is school meal debt
created there's a lot of ways in the
beginning of the school school year you
can have that free and reduced mail
application filled out if you do fill it
out after a couple weeks or months it is
not retroactive so that School Meal debt
stays into the child's account and
therefore it is incurred um I do want to
State there are other ways to be
directly certified and I hope there will
be other ways such as Medicaid direct
certification into that but then again
there will still be School Meal debt so
the school meal debt it's not new every
school that I work with the 40 schools
they do have school meal debt um it is
higher now and it is because there
aren't those systems in place to help
the parents caregivers families be
directly certified into free and reduced
School meals and I do want to remind you
that USDA has come a long way with the
regulations um School meals are healthy
they are yummy the the cine Minis that
are at the school they're actually 50%
or more whole grain you cannot buy those
in the school in the stores the Froot
Loops that are that are served at school
there's regulations they have extra
vitamins minerals and whole grains so I
do want to clarify the those School
meals they're delicious they're
different than what you ate at school I
promise you that I do want to also state
that we have over 255 online testimonies
I do hope you see uh the online
testimonies for this bill just to reduce
the shaming of the child within that
School Meal line um and this is just to
protect the child's well well-being we
do see that if a child is turned away
once they are not going to go back into
that line even if there is money in
their account that shame runs deep the
embarrassment with their peers not only
peers teachers know the financial
situations of the family I do not think
that is right and I urge you ought to
pass on HP 703 thank you very much are
there questions from the
committee no
you not see any thank you very much
thank you
good afternoon once again my name is
Cynthia tibo I'm the mckin vento Le on
for the dairy School
District um there's nothing worse for a
child than to be shamed in front of
one's
peers um and before I say anything else
I just want you to know that um our
nutrition staff and front offices are
wonderful and compassionate people but
when the rules need to be followed it
can seem very harsh to a parent and they
do get they do get upset recently I had
a mom tell me in tears that she that
since she had a balance on her meal plan
her child a third grader was offered
milk and a piece of cheese on a
hamburger roll this child happened to be
lactose intolerant but she was too sh sh
afraid to tell a busy adult about this
problem she told her mother that she
would rather forgo the milk and cheese
sandwich than be seen with it by her
friends the other children would
recognize that she is poor and might
make comments or assumptions this was
heartbreaking for this mother to hear
from her daughter and she broke down and
cried also this is not enough nutrition
for a third grader especially if the
meal is skipped how can a child
concentrate when they aren't full and
happy this child went the entire day
without food
luckily they qualified for mckin vento
and the very next day she was able to
have regular lunch with all of her
friends it would be helpful if any child
could receive the same meal as his or
her peers even if the account is overdue
but how House Bill 703 would be a good
start we must also win the practice of
telling the child to tell his or her
parents to pay the bill I haven't heard
uh much of like this in our district but
I've observed it in other schools we
must find funding to support our most
vulnerable students thank you thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee
members not see I don't see any thank
you very much thank you uh Becky Wilson
good afternoon chairman lad members of
the committee for the record I'm Becky
Wilson from the New Hampshire school
boards Association um we are not taking
a position on this bill although we
certainly support the underlying um goal
of this bill which is to make sure that
students are not taking on uh the
consequences perhaps of issues that have
you know adult decisions involved with
those I did just want to speak for a
moment about the reality of of unpaid
lunch balances and to just give some
context to the conversation about why
the appropriation or the opportunity for
this bill to be able to allow the
department to draw funds to pay off
unpaid lunch balances would certainly
support um students not being in the
position of having to deal with some of
these things um unpaid lunch balances as
many of you may know are are a real cost
in many districts just last year um some
of the districts that we have as members
had unpaid lunch balances of
$992,000
$61,000
$55,000
$30,000 39.5 th000 uh one District in
the first three months of school has
acred
$15,400 of unpaid lunch balances and
$37,000 these are not big districts um
other than the 92,000 but these are real
funds that the taxpayers and the school
boards are having to go back to their
local communities to figure out how to
handle unpaid lunch balances so
certainly the second part of this bill
allowing funds to be drawn to pay off by
the department these unpaid balances
would certain alleviate um some of these
issues that I think this bill is trying
to address um we certainly want students
to be able to be fed regardless of what
the household income is and things like
that um districts I think based off of
these numbers they are feeding kids and
airing on the side of taking care of
students versus making some financially
driven decisions um that could be
discriminatory or call a student out
accidentally Etc um a lot of you know
unpaid lunch balances are addressed with
families but it is a sensitive situation
for school districts to be seeking out
financial information from families um
even though there are resources the
school districts could provide families
if they were to need them and perhaps
some of these families do qualify for
programs that they have not accessed so
uh I just wanted to offer that
information to the committee and I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
are there any questions for the school
boards association yes represent
papovich thank you Mr chair thank you
for being here and uh thank you for
testifying as the you know SBA have you
ever try to put together a complete
summary of school debt between districts
maybe for a few years so we could
understand the magnitude and the nature
of the problem thank you thank you for
the question representative um we do try
to work um our association with other
associations as well in terms of school
administrators Etc to gather Uh current
data on lots of different issues that
this committee and the other education
committees address on a fairly regular
basis um we do try to get that
information it would be um fairly uh
accessible for people to go to their
local Schoolboard budget and find unpaid
lunch balances that is something that
comes up at very frequently at
Schoolboard meetings um but there is no
one place that that is housed so to
speak in terms of a
Statewide um District comparison of
unpaid lunch balances uh also depending
on districts participating um as you
heard previously in the National
programs some districts choose not to
simply because the federal program has
certain limitations um they don't want
those for their students so they opt not
to participate in those programs but um
it does not change the fact that there
is unpaid balance is in many many
districts across the
state further questions that's thank you
very
much I don't have any other pin cards on
this bill so I'm going to close the
hearing
down uh and then we
will go into the LA uh the second to
last bill for the day it's HB
656 relative to the authority of local
school districts to accept federal
grants
does anybody have to take a five minute
break or anything like
that me we're good nobody has to go to
Men's
good okay I I'd like to recognize uh
representative peternell who is the
Prime sponsor of 703 this is a bill
excuse me wrong Bill
56 got change my page here relative to
the authority of local school districts
to accept federal
grants welcome representative Pell thank
you chairman lad and members of the
committee um I am Katie Pell uh wol uh
representing wolfboro Tuftonboro Carol
district 6 um so this this bill
um was kind of a concept that was in
introduced to me and it took a little
bit of time for me to put the work
together to get the language in it and
it I met with um a representative from
sorry an employee of the doe on my on my
way in and it might need a little more
work than I anticipated so I'm just
going to give you a brief overview and
he can probably um address any more of
the technical details so um the purpose
of this is for for accountability and
transparency um regarding these federal
funds that come in and lack of complete
knowledge of what these funds are going
are being used for and to clear up some
of the ambiguity for the taxpayers and
and the parents in the school district
so this is all the one of the changes is
um that all funds dispersed from a
federal governmental unit shall be
deemed to be unanticipated under the
provisions of this section and that is
um to be uh using the example of the
Esser funds as a situation where they
were
originally um anticipated for the course
of three years but the purpose of the
Esser funds was changing so um sometimes
those funds were coming in and um wasn't
always clear what they were being used
for and then we're also adding um that
such notice shall contain a summary of
any obligations incurred by accepting
the unanticipated funds or state that
there are no obligations in curred so
it's very clear what um what the strings
are that are attached to receiving the
funds and the other um thing is that the
other part of this is that the minutes
of the board shall contain a summary of
any obligations so that any taxpayer who
wanted to look at the minutes of the
meeting has a clear understanding of the
purpose of the funds and what they're
what they're going to be used for so
that's essentially it um and I did want
to give one sort of a Kudos if you will
to the New Hampshire Schoolboard
Association and just say yes for
something to be accountable and
transparent parents and taxpayers need
to show up at their Schoolboard
meetings yes thank you uh G to take
questions from us I will try Okay
representative spillsbury
thank you very much is it fair to assume
that by
obligations your intent is both
Financial
obligations as well as commitments to do
something or to not do something exactly
yes would it be useful to make That
explicit possibly I'd be open to any
amendments or suggestions yes it
definitely needs some clearing up I'm
it represent fellows thank you Mr chair
so having worked at the Department of
Education I have some back ground on
this so um has somebody explained to you
that most of the money that comes from
the federal government title one and um
title two that under normal
circumstances and the covid situation
was not normal that those funds are
anticipated and put in the local school
budget that gets voted
on um and that
what that money is used
for uh it's not going to have
detailed information in the minutes but
in very very detailed explanations of
every dollar the State Department of
Education uh
collects um a budget from the school
district on how they're planning to
spend that fund and that they get
reimbursed for spending it in though all
those different minute categories and if
they want to make any changes to the
budget that that gets approved
also thank you for the question on the
way in I believe your successor from the
doe explained all of that to me so he
can probably and go into that in further
detail thank you representative P I have
one question for you here uh if I as a
School District received These funds and
my school board approves the use of them
must I consider any future obligations
that the result of the using these funds
May incur be incurred by the district IE
labor I would think so that's that's as
much as I can elaborate I would think so
yeah future obligations yes that's what
I would
yeah thank you thank
you further
questions yes represent luno so thank
you very much uh Mr chair and thank you
very much for joining us this afternoon
um what is um what are public schools in
New Hampshire currently receiving on an
annual basis from federal um oh I don't
I honestly don't have an answer to that
ballpark and I don't have a ballpark 300
million Mark is there no not all right
thank you thank
you further questions
that's see you thank you very much
represent
dry thank you Mr chairman and good
afternoon to the
committee for the record I'm
representative Margaret dry serve
Sullivan district 7 and I'm one of the
co-sponsors of this bill so I thought I
would just come and back up the sponsor
and just say that um in the rural towns
that I'm in uh it makes a difference
um if you're considering things like
merging uh schools or districts or saus
um what obligations people bring to the
table um without letting anything out of
the bag there I did hear recently of a
town that had to um may
may stop the deal because of the
obligations that they had that um the
other school didn't know about and it
may be the the um the killer on making
some strides towards murder in merg yeah
merging um it's it's important for
transparency and especially in the time
we're asking on the other education
committee uh we're talking about
consolidation of seus and and
consolidation of districts and I think
that that everybody needs to bring to
the table all the obligations that they
have so that we can make a fair
decision thank you thank you any any
questions yes repres McGuire thank you
Mr chair thank you
representative can you be more specific
in in your example of um what kind of
money came in and what kind of
obligation was assumed I mean just
because I'm I'm unfamiliar with this
yeah I think um I think it's more along
the lines of um and I'm not really sure
I just heard about this so um of what
obligations were uh maybe expected from
the money and it made differ uh the
paths May differ in the people that are
trying to merge that's where it's good
to know what they're what they're
expecting to do with with money or the
lack of
it does that help you yes okay so no I
meant more like I don't know the federal
government gives you $50,000 this year
but it requires you to hire for 10 years
a new PE teacher or something you know
what I mean is it something like that or
is it I think full disclosure is good if
you think that you have obligations on
money that we're going to you're going
to add somebody else to take along this
with you um they need to know what
obligations you have kind of like full
house represent fellows um yes I'm my
question is along that same line because
the
only situation I can think of for
Federal money that had a really
multi-year um you know more than beyond
the next year or so obligation was is
Charter School startup money regular
school districts I I don't think for
their Title One money that is doesn't
work that way it wouldn't be that kind
of obligation that would be far ahead
and whenever there's a merger that
doesn't happen overnight so yeah that's
true so can does that help you can does
that help you explain what this
situation could be no we're talking
about Federal money here yes okay that
that may make a difference maybe I'll
just up here to say transparency helps
uh this is a good bill because it's
pushing that concept and if you have to
work out the business with Title One
money like representative pel said um
road okay thank thank you I'm going to
follow up with a question I just to try
and qualify what I was trying to say
earlier if I receive eser monies in a
school district and I'm complying with
federal law so I'm able to hire this
individual who may be a par
professional if I don't put in the
contract with that parah or the
agreement that this is only for two or
three years and I don't have that
language in there what's going to happen
when you get to the end of the three
years and that person's become a part of
that school is that in making an
obligation that's going to incur that
District into having to pay then raise
the the next fourth year from property
taxes sounds to me like that's the
case
yeah represent no s so thank you thank
you very much Mr chair I I just want to
um uh poke on on representative lad's
question a little bit more and your
answer so are you saying that under no
circumstances after a um after employees
contract has expired um as a result of a
grant expiration that the school board
would not have the authority to um to
non-renew that contract are you saying
the school board does not under current
law have the authority to do that to not
non-renew to non non-renew a contract
after it's expired and after funding has
run out from Federal
grant no not necessarily not necessarily
that the school board does not have
Authority or the school board does have
the authority to non-renew a
contract the single School we're talking
about one school district not talking
about school district non-renewing a
contract in the case that representative
lad just talked about was funded for
multiple years through a Federal Grant
and it and it states CLE L on the
contract as all the ones that I've ever
signed being chair of the school board
that this this contract is being issued
subject to a Federal Grant and um and is
subject to non-renewal um uh following
the termination following the completion
of the grant are you saying that school
boards don't have the authority to to
non-renew a contract no because you just
said that they could they they clearly
do and you just said that maybe they
don't to representative lad's
question they school boards clearly have
the authority if you've got the answer
to your question then that's not well
well then a followup on that I think
you've had a
followup Point um further questions yes
representative Amon thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question can you share with us what
percent of funding for New Hampshire
Public Schools comes from federal grants
I don't know that
number do you know it as a dollar figure
don't but she
might it's not her daily way represent
fellow so do you think that maybe it's
7% or around that figure possibly it is
yes thank you very
much further
questions thank you very much thank you
good afternoon chairman lad members of
the committee for the record Becky
Wilson from the New Hampshire school
boards Association uh we are in
opposition of this bill as it is
currently written uh if the bill does
move forward we have a lot of questions
about what this would mean for districts
um we certainly understand the need for
transparency and wanting uh local
community members and parents to attend
local Schoolboard meetings to the
representatives Point earlier is
something that we would love to have
that kind of involvement however we're
confused about whether or not this bill
if it's enacted the way that it's
currently written means that districts
need to budget all of the monies that
they're currently receiving through
federal grants into their operating
budget and have that raised locally uh
by their local communities that would be
a very large burden for a lot of
communities to take the money they're
currently anticipating although it's not
a for sure dollar amount that they are
counting on through these other grants
things like idea grants right now in the
state I think idea allocations to the
districts are about $50 million I think
title one is around $45
million um I'm not sure what other
federal grants would fall under this
bill but it's a significant amount of
money that would then need to be I
believe somehow incorporated into
District's operating budgets with no um
guarantee or act as if there's no
guarantee that they're going to get any
of these funds through these federal
grants uh most of the federal grants
also do require uh a maintenance of
effort meaning if you're going to put
something into place through a grant
that you are anticipating maintaining
over time or a resource to families you
do have to somehow account for that
moving forward in your operating budget
to ensure that you're not just providing
something and then taking it away from
students and families uh in the future
but you can to the previous question um
as a person's contract that is solely
funded by a grant make sure that that is
known and then when that Grant is over
you that position would be no longer um
maintained by the district uh Grant
activities are also already deeply
approved by the New Hampshire Department
of Education to ensure that they are
allowable activities based on the grant
um the goals of the grants and the
outlines of each Grant um every single
activity in those grants that districts
are applying for or are allocated
through uh have to be approved down to
the penny it's fairly specific so that
information is available if anyone were
to ask for it in your District um and
you certainly cannot supplant things
from your budget into grants fully you
can only supplement with the grant I'm
happy to answer any questions further
questions representa
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question which I wish I
thought of asking previously are you
aware of any situations in recent years
where a district planned on grant
funding and then didn't receive it and
there were costs incourage to the
district because of that uh thank you
for the question
representative there are there's a
difference between federal grants that
are anticipated and allocated to the
district on a regular basis idea things
like that versus a competitive Grant
where perhaps you would be part of a
process where you're applying for a
grant as a district and you may or may
not get it um districts make decisions
based on what they put in place prior to
applying for those competitive grants
meaning if they f it was important to
put something into their school district
and fund it regardless of where the
funding is coming from I think districts
would do that if it is based solely on
whether or not they win a competitive
Grant or are allowed certain allocations
off of a grant that is a new like the
safe grants for example uh for building
safety things like that that's up that's
a district decision to decide whether or
not to move forward with costs that they
may or may not have Grant support
for thank you represent spilsbury thank
you Mr chairman um it seems like a
pretty straightforward bill it's making
three very small changes to notice
requirements so it's been described as a
full disclosure uh
Bill if it's only requiring that the
notice given includes a summary of
obligations and that the minutes that
are already required includes that
summary can you point us to the language
gives the association
pause thank you for the question
representative I think that this while
it does seem straightforward in terms of
its intention and I hear that from the
representative sponsors on this bill I
think it is a bit confusing to say that
what obligations are incurred by taking
for example Federal idea
funds those those are federal funds that
the districts are already um you know
that are set aside for districts to be
able to offset their C for special
education for example or Title One um
you know what you're providing with
those Services I would imagine would be
the obligations that you're incurring so
to speak which is that you're going to
provide special ed services in
accordance with the law or you're going
to provide Title One support in
accordance with the title one act but
I'm not sure what beyond that um this
bill would be seeking to
publicize follow up sure so I'm just
trying to understand and see whether the
objection is one that can be
addressed it sounds like your concern is
in line six and seven in the way that
the term funds dispersed from a federal
government unit is used is is that
really the point that that somehow is
not sufficiently described or bounded
thank you for the question I I do think
that it is UN unclear to local school
board members as to what would what
would fall under any all funds dispersed
from a federal government unit does that
mean all of grants is it just
competitive grants is it un for example
the SR money or some of those things
that were in response to the to the
times as opposed to something that is an
ongoing grant that districts are used to
getting over time well thank you so I
think that allows us to put a focus on
those that
phrase further questions yes represent
papovich thank you Mr chair I'll be very
brief thank you for taking my question
and
testifying given that you are probably
one of the more knowledgeable people in
the state in terms of what schools do
and that your answer a bit earlier was I
imagine that it's about in this ballpark
wouldn't there be value in your opinion
to the taxpayers to have a clear
accounting from the district as to what
those obligations are instead of them
having to apply their much less
knowledgeable Minds to the problem and
try to guess what it
is isn't that value to the taxpayer just
trying to understand end your stance
thank you thank you for the question
representative I believe that this body
just last year passed a bill that will
require certain things to be posted on
the district website in terms of what
allocations are already being provided
to the district from the Department of
Education which is the flowr for all of
these funds so I'm not sure I mean it's
very specific in terms of what is posted
and how it's labeled I'm not sure what
beyond that you're you would be looking
for districts to be providing to the
community members in terms of making
sure that the transparency that this
bill is seeking is
met you're welcome are there further
questions yes R Kofa thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so I knowing that the New
Hampshire school boards Association
provides uh a number of training
opportunities for Schoolboard members
for member boards um does does your
organization offer any training for
Schoolboard members with respect to
understanding uh potential obligations
and the implications of those
obligations uh for Schoolboard members
who are voting to accept federal funds
thank you for the question
representative and thank you for your
service on your own local board um we do
a number of trainings on budgeting on
operating budgets on School District
communication with the community and
between superintendent and School Board
relations there are many parts of that
running effective meetings um ensuring
that there's strong communication all of
those pieces would fall under I believe
making sure that local school board
members understand their obligations
when they are dealing with the Manifest
monthly when they are signing off on
those things when they're taking actions
at their local Schoolboard meetings on
budget any further
questions not seeing thank you very much
thank
you are there any other cards on this
bill
represent not
repres yeah we I think we have was there
too well come on up if you if you had
one we shall yeah we will we will find
them
and so with Miss Banfield as well you're
more the button push down the bottom
yeah there you go thank you chairman lad
members of the committee I'm darus hoeny
a former nationville School Board member
and I'm here in support in my four years
on the school board never once did the
administration come to the board in
advance asking for input on an
application for a Federal grant we were
only notified after after the grant was
awarded and administration needed our
vote to accept the money details were
always minimal and my understanding was
there were many times when it would
include a position it didn't say you had
to keep it but that was the Assumption
when you get a new director of something
in the grant now you have a new position
going forward but there may be a variety
of different grants when asked why the
administration couldn't come to the
board sooner um to have input into the
application the excuse of was the
deadlines are imminent so there was
never time to seek guidance from the
board these federal funds were like the
administration's own little slush fund
that could predetermine how they would
like the money
spent the commissioner of Education
created a document for districts asking
the superintendent and the board
president to certify that school board
was fully informed of federal funds
coming into the district it was a great
idea apparently my district signed and
certified the board that the board was
fully informed without notifying the
board of any federal funds when caught
in this fraud I was accused of
destroying the district as the federal
funds from the state were stopped for a
whole week nothing ever happened to
those committing the fraud and the board
was barely informed of the federal funds
coming to the district anything you can
do to make this process more transparent
would be appreciated in fact I'd like a
study to determine if any of the federal
funds are costeffective given that only
88.4% according to the department's
website of the education revenue or 336
million
um comes from federal funds how much
does it cost districts to implement
these Federal programs and restoring
local control over curriculum would
encourage diversity of instruction
eliminate Data Tracking that would
respect the new privacy amendment to our
constitution thank you for your time and
attention Doris do you want to take any
questions sure you have any any
questions from the
committee yes represent BB I'm thinking
of another bill that I sponsored which
is in the education policy and
administration committee and I'm
wondering whether you think there should
be more explicit language in law
defining the extent of the budget
committee's role and what the school
board and superintendent must bring to
the budget committee before it's agreed
I'm thinking outside the budget cycle
things that occur during the year thank
you for your question I'm in a city so
we don't have Town budgets Town voting
we get delet well in January the
superintendent comes with a proposed
budget which he gives us in pieces week
by week we don't get the whole thing we
just get his summary takes us four to
six weeks for him to go through and for
us to try to get some detail it's really
hard when you have 17 schools in one
District it's it's really hard I never
got sufficient information federal funds
is anything you can do to
useful thank you yeah I I just have one
you you spoke of these federal funds and
my memory servicing back to co and all
that esm money that came down is this
bill partially a result of
superintendent spending money even with
on is that question well I said is this
bill a result
of the way the federal government set up
the Essa which was really done in a very
quick fashion that monies came down and
there were some cases in which those
monies were being and there was a very
broad list of how things could be used
and for
what and it was the understanding that
the superintendent administrators could
make the decision how those fun it did
not go to school boards so the
transparency is that so that there were
somewhere they weren't even formed that
they had this money and it's being
spent are you aware thank you for the
question I think it's interesting I was
off the board at that time the boards
were not meeting in person they were
meeting over Zoom information transfer
was minimal um Essa is a very strange
animal passed in
2015 as comes in in 2019 and it somehow
mandates something that came four years
later they don't go back to Congress
they it just Essa keeps blooming yeah I
excuse me I wasn't talking ESS if I was
talking AR but go go for monies Co money
through Essa you said Co money yes I
wasn't there
yeah
yeah further
questions okay we have one more card
good afternoon Amry Banfield I'm a
parental rights Advocate New Hampshire
focused on excellence and
education I have 91a many of these
grants and read through them and was
appalled not because of what they intend
to do but a lot of times it's what's
missing um and again I look at it from a
parental rights perspective so sometimes
that's what I'm focused in on
for instance Nelly May uh receives Grant
or receives money from The Gates
Foundation and the federal government
and Nelly May is one of the grant
foundations that come into our school
and you may not know this but they
actually dictate teaching methods in the
classroom when those grants come into
the into the school so reading the
details of a grant is I just can't even
believe that that's not
happening quite frankly I think it
should be put on the website I think we
I think everybody should be able to
access it and just think you wouldn't
have to 91a it you wouldn't have to take
their time so transparency is what I
like about this I'd love it on the
website but that's me um so I've you
know I'm going to kind of focus in on um
one of this grants because I think that
I can explain why this is so important
so uh Manchester received Community
School Grants Community School is a CDC
model so that means going to take the
school and what used to be the education
focused on education we're now going to
incorporate medical services and mental
health services so it's One-Stop
shopping for your
child um if you want an example of where
this where a uh there's been a problem
with school boards not seeing other than
U Mrs hoeny what she what she brought to
you uh just a few months ago in seab
Brook uh they had accepted a community
school Grant and the board then voted to
get rid of the grant because they didn't
like the details the details that they
didn't know about that were not shared
with them by the administration so once
they figured out once they saw the
details they then rejected it you can go
back to the minutes you can talk to this
to the school board members about that
they then also voted to uh look at all
grants above $225,000 so that is now a
policy uh first of all Community Schools
I'm not aware of statutory authority to
even have them I know that they with
their statutory authority to hire a
school nurse but this is a fundamental
change to our education system and it's
coming into our schools already with
Federal
money Massachusetts has an extensive
statute on Community Schools but I'm
going to tell you in Maine for instance
Maine has many school-based health
clinics and I'll give an example there a
father went in and or I'm sorry a
daughter brought home a little bag of
pills and father said what are those
pills and she said well they prescrib
them at
school and he found out that they're
Zoloft and zolof does um is a u
anti-depressant and it causes um
suicidal thoughts and my point is he
went into the school found out from the
administrator that oh we don't do this
this is school-based Health Clinic where
we got our Federal Grant from goes to
that entity they tell him we don't have
to get your consent this is federal
money we don't need your consent he
withdraws his daughter and Children
Services come and visit him which he was
then
exonerated So within this grant uh
I'm going to give you another example so
some of the some of the wording in the
grant talks
about the behavioral health Improvement
Institute at Keen State College will
serve as the outside evaluator for
measuring performance pipeline services
and local outcomes that's part of the
community Grant to the Manchester
schools now does anybody have any
concerns about Keen State College
Behavior Institute probably none of you
do you may not know this but they are
they are the outside Authority who
reports back to the federal government
on how these grants are working in the
school and so just a short time ago
maybe about a year ago uh we determined
or we found out that Keen state was
receiving personally identifiable
information on students mental health
without parental consent without student
consent
so there's a problem so this is in their
Grant CH so I Mr chair point of order
what's your point of order um the bill
talks about um any obligations inur U
incurred by accepting um unanticipated
funds it doesn't talk about specific
detail associated with the grant so
these are just stories that I think are
anecdotal to the um stories that are
reinforcing the rationale for the
purpose of of the bill um no because the
the purpose of the bill is is is
obligations incurred by the school
district by accepting the unanticipated
funds it's not about um I'm not I'm not
going to accept this parliamentary
inquiry I don't feel that the person
testifying is straying off the path I
would ask her to continue thank you Mr
chair so as I go through this Grant and
again I look at from a parental rights
perspective uh one of the things I look
for is parental consent when they're now
going to service a child for their
medical needs or their mental health
needs and in this particular Grant to
for Manchester there is language
fortunately that requires parental
consent but the problem is that I saw
was it's is this a blanket consent form
or is this for each service we just had
Manchester um testify that they don't in
in uh Ruth Wards uh she was expanding
medic Medicaid parental consent so if uh
again these blanket forms app parent
signs could be used as uh well we're
going to change something on on the
Medicaid billing we're going to change
services it doesn't specify that a
parent needs to consent on each each
service that they provide another
example because I maybe you want
examples maybe you don't but I did have
a parent one day call me and say that um
and the commissioner knows about this I
report all this to the commissioner
um that his son was in the lunchroom and
they were playing swords with their
knives with the plastic knives and his
son scraped the arm of his friend he
goes down he gets a psychological
evaluation is that is that resulting of
of the the language which are the point
is that there was not parental consent
for that psychological evaluation and
that's a big issue in these grants is
they're doing these Services providing
Services sometimes with a blanket
consent so in terms of transparency yes
I do believe this is why I think it's so
important for Schoolboard members to
read these grants and maybe they would
miss something like that I don't know
maybe it's because I I look at them and
I see that but yes I think that is
extremely important to um to to read
these grants I think it's important that
everybody in the community you know if
they're interested read these grants um
the other thing is that and again this
comes directly from their documentation
that they sent me uh that they're
they're they're talking about the
Community Schools approach with better
with braided funding and B better data
sharing there's there's we have
loopholes in data privacy sharing
through furpa so again this is something
that at Schoolboard members should be
reading should be looking at making sure
that the data that is being shared is
that personally that we don't have
enough laws to cover that but if I was a
Schoolboard member I would say in my
contract no this is not acceptable
rewrite it with more data protections
for the students
um they part they're partnering with
Manchester proud to create a coordinated
system of Community
Partnerships and the district
established a position specifically
dedicated to equity within its
leadership structure known as a chief
Equity officer so Within These Grant
there's more people being hired a lot of
this money is not getting to the
students in terms of you know uh just
helping them
educationally um I just wanted to share
some examples because I think that you
need to know what's going on with these
grants and if a school board says yes
we've read it we liked it so be it but I
transparency sorry that's it than you
very much are there any
questions rep Maguire thank you Mr
chairman thank you Miss Manfield
so am I hearing you correctly that you'd
like to have uh more notice more
transparency and so on not just
necessarily for federal grants like this
bill is about but for all grants I would
yes and you're less concerned about this
business of making federal grants
unanticipated money and thereby possibly
making some difficulty for budgeting
purposes um in terms of how that all
works the interconnectedness with the
budget I wouldn't be able to speak to
that I don't know that I'm telling you
that in terms of what I know about these
grants that the devil's in the details
and anybody just signing off on them I
think you know the seabook example is is
perfect that you know they really didn't
know what was in it you know they kind
of signed it and didn't know it was in
it until it was too late and then they
said we don't want the grant anymore um
had they been required to and of course
now they are because it's in their
policy um you know the devil's in the
details thank you are there further
questions yes represent
Earth thank you Mr speaker thank you for
my question should this bill be enhanced
to make specific reference to to the
superintendent's responsibility to do
this as well to to the responsibility to
inform the boards of what the boards are
being required to report here um
technically I don't know that that
answer I would say somebody within the
administration either maybe they have a
grant person within the school that's
that's doing that job somebody needs to
make this the school board aware
somebody needs to provide this
documentation to I can get it through a
91a anybody can get it um but the school
board should review them them before
accepting the money
absolutely further questions yes
represent Damon thank you Mr chair thank
you for my taking my question in the
interest of transparency would you
please follow up with the committee with
the contact info and the specifics of
the grant situations that you referenced
concerns about specifically including
the main one um so that we can follow up
and do our due diligence oh so you would
um all of the examples you cited because
they are I'm hearing them as anecdotal
examples I I can do that for Maine the
dad that contacted me I would have to
keep that information confidential I did
share it with the commissioner you're
more than welcome to speak to him he
knows I gave him the information um but
when it comes to specific people who
contact me a lot of times I keep that uh
information confidential but I'm but in
in terms of Maine that that's already
publicized I'm happy to do that um
trying to think what else I brought up
is there anything else
Maine I mean Maine you can Google that
one um representative Heidi Samson who
served in Maine is well aware of what
went down with all of that she's no
longer serving in the legislature but
she was one of the people that um
specifically told me the
details further further
questions n see thank you very much and
that concludes the testimony for that
bill we have one bill left that's uh 716
making an appropriation for the Dual and
concurrent enrollment
program I'm going to have to go present
get yeah that's right that's I can do Mr
chairman Mr
chairman it's me um I I got a note from
the lobby asking if we're going to be
executing any bills this afternoon after
this the answer to that is
it all right we will open the hearing
for hb76
thank you very
muches represent spillsbury and members
of the committee I'm here today to
introduce Bill HB 716 my name is Rick
lad I come from hail New Hampshire uh
this bill is relative to the concurrent
enrollment program and which we have
through the community the Dual and
concurrent enrollment program which we
have through the university uh Community
uh uh community college system which
works with our schools and in the past
we've uh allocated this uh sum of a $2.5
million this is asking for $3 million we
have since uh we initiated this program
uh where we once had grades 11 and 12
students eligible we have grades 10 11
and 12 right now so that does result in
uh additional costs we also know that by
putting forward this program where the
uh students in the high school and in
the dual enrollment program taught at
the Collegiate level um the the it can
take these courses for $150 we we talked
about that per course and that could be
a net Savings of later on when that
would student would had it done it as a
as a an older student out of high school
a cost for all of them to do this the
aggregate would be over I believe over
$10 million that's a huge saving so it's
putting forth the dollar now uh to
enrich the program to allow us to
facilitate what we have designed that
program for and it would be an increase
the budget which we see in hb1 supported
by hb2 by $500,000 a
year that concludes my testimony a model
questions yes representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question so
as I understand this program this is a
high school student taking a class or
two at community college and um
shouldn't the cost of that be borne by
the school district since they no longer
have the obligation for teaching that
student during that period of time the
student at the same time is getting
credit for graduating from high school
so it's concurrent you get dual and
credit as a college course and for that
High School course um and it has to be
taught in conjunction with the
particular standards that the the univer
community college system has been
authorized by their accrediting board
which are you have to have in this state
the Masters and you also have to have
the the uh same course materials and the
the same curriculum that is used for
that course at the college campus so
that would have to be done at the
community college at the high school
representative papovich and then Fells
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for
testifying
um does participating in this program
require any additional expenses for the
school
districts for the school districts
correct for the school districts we know
the college is doing some work if in
fact you have an instructor that's
already there that's capable of doing
this that has the Masters let's say in
the mathematics that's part of their
contract contract so they're doing at no
cost to the school district however
there is a cost of $150 for that cost
through the community college system but
there should be no additional cost to
the uh unless for example you do not
have the instructor at your school that
has the math and they bring that
instructor down from the community
college system then there there could be
an expense to the to pay from the school
district to pay that person to do
that representative fellas yeah just a
followup to that question so so the
money the
$3,000 3 million three million
sorry um most of it is probably going to
the
$150 per student but but some of it
might go to pay an a a community college
instructor
to we have the we have the chancellor
here along with the community college
system
and the money that I see in this bill is
for the $150 to pay for that course that
allows us to have that Savings of 10
plus million dollar in the long run uh
if if they hadn't taken those courses
there that's what it would cost us as
courses okay see no further questions
thank you and I'll get my pink card
good come up CH jointly
okay and we don't have any other P cards
right here okay uh good I'm going to
call jointly uh Chancellor Mark
system thank you very much I'm here to
speak on behalf of this bill if I may
begin with a point of
clarification uh to represent Maguire's
question there are actually three
different formats for Early College one
is in the high schools and typically
taught by the high school teacher who's
academically qualified to deliver our
curriculum that proba accounts for about
90% of the activity but the other two
versions include on our campuses with
our faculty and online and those account
between them for another 10% of the
activity so some of this is borne by the
school district through the compensation
of teachers some by our folks up until
the current bium the language in statute
for this was specifically to fund
scholarships for courses and originally
CTE and stem cour is eventually
broadened and from our bant Point
perhaps most helpfully giving us some
latitude to support the program when we
do have an instance where a school
district may not have a teachers able to
offer part of the curriculum for us to
be able to step in uh with our with our
instructors to support
that as representative lad described in
the last year uh we had over 10,000
students participate in Early College
across that group of students they
earned about 54,000 credits at our
tuition rate that would have been about
$13 million so the $2.5 million that
supported that had a return on
investment that is the 10 million that
representative lad is describing last
year we saw 15% growth year-over-year
the current year uh spring is not yet
completed but we're probably looking at
about 10% year-over-year continued
growth we'll probably approach 60,000
credits delivered again for the same
$2.5 million this year as last year so
the return on investment growing that
return on investment that we calculate
is based on our tuition $215 of credit
and $25 enrollment fee if that student
is enrolling at the University system
where tuition rates are essentially
twice that you can you can in some
double the savings if you're looking at
a private institution uh significantly
more so we've used the most conservative
way of describing what we think is the
return on investment for the states
funds not coming to ccsnh but return on
investment in terms of value to students
and families a point that was made
earlier typically students are taking
just one or two courses and what we've
been working on to try and grow this is
help students actually take sets of
courses for a student who's going on to
college to take one or two courses may
make a semester a little bit lighter
give them a little bit more flexibility
but where the real impact shows up is
when a student can complete a full
semester's worth of college or a full
year or even the associate degree while
still in high school because that year
or two of savings that they're not
paying for college that they're not
taking out loans and a year or two more
rapidly into the workforce is just
significantly more beneficial for them
and frankly for New Hampshire's
Workforce so the object jective that we
have is to offer students enough
opportunity to take courses that they
can actually complete that meaningful
block whether it's again a semester or a
year or more before they actually find
themselves graduated from high school
the other thing that I would want you to
know about this effort about 30% of the
credits earned by students in Early
College last year or students who were
enrolled in Career Technical Education
Centers now in our high schools those
students represent about 10 or 12% of
the enrollment but they're over
represented in participation we think
that this is starting to reach those
students for whom opportunity may have
been uh more more distant and it's in a
range of Fields Automotive students who
are interested in welding students who
are interested in health care virtually
any field that we offer students can get
the
foundation started earlier and more
affordably gives them more options
as they progress so we we think that
there's real value to the state in this
program we've seen students and families
embrace it uh we think that it it it's
worthwhile for the state to continue to
support this effort and I'm happy to
answer any questions you might have I'm
also joined by my colleague Shauna young
director of secondary Pathways who can
answer the more detailed
questions very good thank you yes
representative mire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so what fraction of high
schools participate in this program and
does VX participate VX does for the
online portion of this and we serve I
want to say it's at least a 100 high
schools across the state virtually every
this yes representative B thank you
thank you for um the question the the
the advantage to the program correct me
if I'm wrong is that these courses
articulate with University and college
courses not just the community college
system and does it not give the parents
assurance that their their son or
daughter will get a leg up on that
education that they won't have to pay
for at the next
level comp completely correct a student
who
earns credits on through Early College
receives a transcript from from ccsnh if
they happen to be at Oyster River High
School the transcript is from Great Bay
Community College if they happen to be
here in conquer it may be from
nhti it is a ccsnh course a ccsnh
transcript and the credits apply and as
you probably know over the last several
years as we've worked with the
university system to build Pathways
between the two programs students not
only have more assurance that these
credits transfer and apply to those
degrees but actually can map out what
the degree path should look like so no
wasted time money no lost credits and in
the long term as this state has tended
to see majority of its students who are
going to fouryear colleges go out of
state to do that we think that we can
use these Pathways to help New Hampshire
students find opportunities in New
Hampshire schools to stay here thank you
thank you represent represent fellows
thank you um is there a cost to the you
to the community college system to get
these teachers certified to to be able
to teach these courses well T typically
we're working with high schools and
identifying teachers who are already
academically qualified have the required
master's degree in the discipline that
they'll be teaching we invest in we have
Early College coordinators working with
schools throughout the state each of our
colleges has a a person whose role is to
work with colleges work with guidance
councils work with teachers recruit
students to help with the registration
process so we we're not actively working
to prepare teachers to be certified but
we are working with school districts to
help them understand what the
opportunties are and in places where a
district may not have somebody again
pointing back to the opportunities we
can offer on our
campuses you're welcome yes
representative Miller
I appreciate it any short form of it
works for me um and thank you for coming
and testifying and answering questions I
think it would be useful to all of us
and me in particular if maybe either you
or your colleague would go into detail
and explain exactly what the funds are
going to be what what are they getting
spent on you know you receive this
Revenue what are your costs what do you
do with the money exactly so you know we
can better understand how the process
works okay so some of of this is
specifically invested in the staff who
provide that Outreach to the colleg uh
to the colleges to the high schools but
some of it is also in anticipation of
Revenue that we're
relinquishing um the about one in five
credits that we offer about 20% are in
math courses and to be able to offer
math courses those tend to be larger
enrolled courses tend to be if if we
were think about this purely in business
terms those are are Revenue
positive helps us to offset the cost of
things that are not as as uh financially
feasible on their own our nursing
programs Alli dental health programs
that are smaller course required by
accreditation in some ways this goes to
expenses thank you very much I I would
concur with the request for a rough
breakout of how the 3 million would be
expended if you could do that in the
categories I I I if I go through the
current Staffing that we have the costs
associated with recruitment Outreach
administering the program as it is about
a million and a half is offset by those
operating expenses some of this would
also be used and again with the broader
language that allows us to support
programs we'd be looking to create
opportunities for students who are
participa in these courses to come to
our campuses because part of this is
helping them understand what the
opportunities are to meet our faculty
see our facilities increase the
likelihood that they'll persist Beyond
High School into these programs both
with us and with the university system
and then some portion I can't tell you
uh exactly what it is if if it's the $3
million some portion of that would flow
to the bottom line to offset those
expenses that associated with courses
that are more costly to
deliver as I said earlier with with a
math class because we can have larger
enrollment that Course May cost us
$120 per credit to deliver because we
spread that across a two dozen students
our nursing classes typically are
costing us between $650 and $700 a
credit some of our Automotive
classes Advanced manufacturing classes
may be $3 and $400 per credit to deliver
so some of this as you wash through the
full spectrum of our curriculum there
are always courses that are Revenue
positive and courses that are very
costly to deliver and and some of this
is just figuring out how to make sure
that we can provide the full spectrum of
Education that the state needs for the
workforce that the state
wants okay very good yes do you know if
you have any um homeschoolers that are
taking that's coming back to the high
school and the other thing is do you
offer anything comparable at private
schools like
this sure yes on both occasions so the
early college program is yes could you
please step forward and use the mic and
pull the mic towards you why don't you
just take a seat for a moment all right
sorry than you um no the early college
program is open to both homeschool
students Traditional High School
students as well as private high schools
um for the private high schools they
will need to have an or an memor
memorandum of understanding with us um
but the program is offered to a vast
families yes representative Damon thank
you could one of you speak to what
portion of students who do one or more
dual income enrollment courses continue
in higher ed whether with the community
college system or otherwise and also
what portion of of those students um are
New Hampshire residents so V virtually
all of them in New Hampshire high
schools are New Hampshire residents
there are some folks on the on the edges
of Vermont and Maine that we we see but
I put it at 98% New Hampshire to your
question we actually have very good data
we we looked at the period from 2015 to
2022 in part just to be able to see what
happens to students after so students
who participated in Early College dur
during that period of time we served
about 35,000 students what we found is
about 80% of them go on to postsecondary
education about 6,000 of those 35,000
ended up at some point at the community
college
system about 6600 ended up at the
University system we know that the
majority of students who participate in
early college at least in that period of
time ended up going to four-year
Institutions and those students the
majority actually went out of state so
one of the things that we've seen in the
last couple of years is a growth in
participation of students in our Career
Technical Education Centers whose
interests we think are better aligned
with many of the technical programs we
have we expect that as those data become
more current more recent years where
we've seen that growth we're going to
see more of those students coming to the
community college system and more of the
students staying in New Hampshire even
for the students who are bound heading
toward four-year institutions we think
that growing concerns about
affordability plus the opportunity for
them to be better engaged to these
programs can bring more of those
students to New Hampshire schools rather
than having them go out of state with
earning and one last data piece do you
have any knowledge to share
on how many many of the Dual and
concurrent enrollment students are
students who would not likely have gone
to college if this program wasn't
brought to them in high school or made
available to them in high school so this
is another one of those questions where
we think the more recent data will be
different than the historic data when
this program was first created and this
kind of early college program exists
around the country the original intent
was to give students the opportunity to
test themselves to demonstrate for
themselves that they could be successful
with college level learning what's
happened for the most part is that
students who already knew they were
headed to college and their parents
financially Savvy said let's let's get
some of this covered early and so the I
think the early years what we've seen is
a disproportionate share of students who
would either take an AP course or an
honors course or an early college course
as we begun to reach more students
through the CTE I think we're starting
to see that student for whom College
wasn't always a certainty and and
particularly as I I described earlier on
a lot of the technical programs when I
was in high school you were either in a
college prep curriculum or Vocational
Technical curriculum those are starting
to blend more and there there's almost
no field of technology or the trades
that doesn't require some level of
advanced education and if we can help
students regardless of what it is they
want to study get the foundation that
they need it's going to help them so
we're starting to see through the growth
in enrollment among CTE Center students
I think more of that broadening of the
pipeline bringing more students to the
opportunities that will be helpful for
them you're
welcome very good okay yes
representative mire thank you Mr
chairman thank you have any um school
districts or students who want to
participate in the program been turned
away due to lack of
funds not in the period of time
that we've I've been hearing that we've
had this funding what we do currently
have though is a limitation of two
courses per student so there are
students for whom taking that third
course becomes an issue of whether the
family has the additional funds and
there may be students who when they've
exhausted the $150 scholarship and again
that's a $150 for course that if they
came to us tuition and fees would be a
for if it's a four credit course would
be essentially a
$960 value there may be students who
have have been dissuaded by the need to
find the 150 follow up could such
students pay with their own private
funds and take more classes and students
can and and I'm sure have thank you
you're welcome sir so that seems to be
the context of the scholarship
characterization
good any other
questions very good thank you for your
testimony um I'm going to close the
hearing and uh that's our our last I
don't think there's anybody else signed
up to speak that's our last bill but if
everyone would sit tight till our chair
has a chance to retake his seat I'll let
well Chancellor Rubenstein and the folks
you brought thank you very very much uh
uh the community college system is
really I feel Rick lad speaking done an
awful lot to blend uh what you do with
the Career Technical Education Centers
and with our high schools so it's not
just K through 12 now you're you're
working collaboratively and it's
probably going to save us a great deal
of money even with our CTE centers if we
can get those students that are involved
in this program engaged in some of that
program may be done down at uh
Manchester or nhti so uh really welcome
what you're you're you're you're doing
thank you again you're doing for us now
what you did at Granite
State thank you uh are there okay at
this point in time we have nothing else
on the dock so we're going to close the
today's hearings down and adjourn and we
come back on Thursday where we're
hearing bills and then our Friday we
have in the morning as a workshop work
session on four special education bills
where we will start to really dig down
and look at that formula for both
differentiated Aid and catastro special
education Aid I I got I can't call it
cat Aid anymore it's special education
Aid so thank you very much and everybody
you I I can't hear my artillery ears are